hi everyone welcome to day two of the
cybersecurity week on day one we learnt
everything about cryptography today we
are going to focus on ethical hacking
ethical hacking is defined as the
process by which system vulnerabilities
are discovered to ensure system security
this is achieved with the help of
hacking techniques and tools an ethical
hacker is a trained individual who
carries out this duty today you're going
to learn what is ethical hacking the
types of hackers who an ethical hacker
is ethical hacker skills the career of
an ethical hacker ethical hacking tools
ethical hacking process etc
so let's begin and continue our cyber
security journey today
you might have heard of several cyber
attack cases where companies have lost
their crucial data money reputation and
customer trust
these attacks are carried out by hackers
who exploit weaknesses in a computer
network to gain unauthorized access to
vital information
however hacking is not always bad as
there are hackers who work with
different motives
white hat hackers also known as ethical
hackers hack with permission to defend
an organization
this form of hacking is legal it is
known as ethical hacking
ethical hacking is distributed into six
different phases the first phase is
reconnaissance where you collect all the
required information
next is the scanning phase where you try
to spot any system vulnerability
following this is the gaining access
phase where the spotted vulnerabilities
are exploited
in the next stage known as maintaining
access you try to maintain your access
for future attacks by installing back
doors
the fifth phase is clearing tracks where
you clear all the evidence of the hack
and finally in the reporting phase you
document the summary of the entire
attack
there is and there will always be high
demand for ethical hackers who can
safeguard organizations from cyber
attacks
so what are you waiting for get
certified with simply learn and become
an ethical hacker and put an end to the
cyber attacks in the world now let's
begin with who is a certified ethical
hacker a certified ethical hacker is a
person who is also known as ethical
hacker an ethical hacker is just the
opposite of a hacker a hacker is a
person who with malicious intent tries
to misuse vulnerabilities that they have
identified in an organization's
structure and then gain access to
unauthorized data whereas an ethical
hacker does the same thing they try to
locate the weakness they try to look at
the vulnerabilities and they see how
they can be misused however the intent
is completely different and that is what
differentiates a hacker from an ethical
hacker hacker would be a criminal with a
malicious intent who would try to misuse
and personally gain by doing criminal
activity from that particular activity
that they have done whereas ethical
hacker would try to help the
organization in an authorized manner so
that's where the permission comes into
the picture the ethical hacker has
permission from the organization to
conduct some activity that would
identify vulnerabilities or weaknesses
in the information technology structure
of that organization and then once they
have been identified the ethical hacker
would then help the organization to plug
those vulnerabilities rather than misuse
those vulnerabilities so any person who
completes ch version 10 certification is
known as a certified ethical hacker so
this is a certification once you
complete that once you pass the exams
you can essentially call yourself as a
certified ethical hacker and you're
going to get a certificate with the same
terminology so as you can see in the
diagram your responsibility would be as
a certified ethical hacker would be with
the proper permission of the
organization with the authorization
coming in with contracts coming in you
would legally help the organization to
identify those weaknesses and
vulnerabilities and once you find them
you're going to report them to the
organization and you're going to help
the organization with remediation plan
which will help them remediate mitigate
and resolve the vulnerabilities that you
have identified thus making the
organization's security structure a lot
better based on which black hat hackers
or malicious hackers would be unable to
attack the organization so what is ch
version 10 now this course was initially
introduced in september 2015 and i think
if you look at the versioning this is
the 10th version that is there in the
market so essentially ch or the
certified ethical hacking course as the
course itself has been for a long time
in the industry it's a very well
accepted course and it's a well-renowned
course the current version as it is was
uh introduced in september 2015 and is
one of the toughest certifications in
the cyber security field this includes a
lot of information that you have to
learn that you have to know before you
can attend the certification you will
master all ethical lacking methodologies
that are used in penetration testing and
ethical hacking situations what does
that mean that means that ceh version 10
is a structured course that will help
you look at all the phases that are used
in ethical hacking all the terminologies
that are utilized all the tools that are
utilized in such a manner that you can
penetration test or a vulnerability
assessment and identify and test the
vulnerabilities for their complexity and
this course once you complete the course
you would have mastered all the ethical
hacking techniques that are required
there are two exams one is a written
exam and the other is a practical exam
now you can opt for either or the
written exam is basically a multiple
choice question exam where they'll ask
you scenario based questions and you
have to answer those questions that is
something that we're going to look into
during this video the practical exam is
basically a simulation exam where they
give you a scenario and you have to
complete some complete those tests and
prove that you are a good ethical hacker
based on the report that you give if the
report tallies to what the test was you
would be clearing that exam so practical
exam is a little bit tougher it's more
hands-on it tests this actual skills
that you would perform in a hacking
scenario or ethical hacking scenario
does the practical exam going to be that
much tougher the written exam to give it
credence tests you a lot on your
mentality on your thought process on
your judgment characteristics so they
will give you a scenario and ask you
what do you think is happening what does
this attack trend amount to or would be
then what what would be the next step in
the particular attack that they're
describing does it's more of an
intellectual test where your when your
thought process are being checked and
you are giving this exam so what would
be the difference between these exams in
a practical exam you would be conducting
all those steps yourself and you would
be reaching a conclusion so here
essentially you're being tested on the
skills that you have developed on the
execution part of it and to see whether
you can execute a test end to end
whereas in a written exam you would be
put in the middle of a test where you
have to assume something where you have
to understand what the steps would have
been performed in the in the previous
steps and what would be the expected
result and you're supposed to analyze
that and then come to the correct answer
so if there is a question which which
exam is better written or practical the
answer to that is from an intellectual
perspective a written exam would be a
lot tougher than a practical exam and
from an execution perspective a
practical exam would be tougher than a
written exam so it depends on us which
exam we want to give both of them are
widely accepted and well respected in
the information security field so it's
just the option that we choose which
exam we want to give now this course the
version 10 course is purely a tag based
course okay it is an offensive course
there's no defensive mechanisms so if
you're looking for questions of how to
secure yourself on the internet how to
securely configure operating system or
how to securely configure a server how
to configure a firewall this is not the
certification this basically talks about
attacking those devices so if you come
across a firewall how would you test a
firewall how would you identify
vulnerabilities in those and how would
you bypass a firewall similarly if you
come across a server how are you going
to attack and hack the server let it be
windows or linux based so this basically
becomes a attack based course you're
looking at offensive mechanisms over
here and not defensive ones at all so
what's new in this version in this
version there's a new module for iot
internet of things it focuses on
emerging attacks vectors like cloud
artificial intelligence and machine
learning it basically talks about smart
devices and it talks about the
vulnerabilities the risks that the smart
devices face in today's world
for example it will tell you about the
industries that are utilizing all these
smart devices why are they utilizing it
for what kind of devices they are
utilizing and what are the risks within
those devices it will also give you a
lot of tools for you to practice upon to
identify such iot devices what would
constitute an iot or internet of things
device any device which has an ip
address and can connect to the internet
and create data so even your smart watch
your smartphone your cars that have
internet connectivity nowadays uh your
google homes amazon alexas all of these
devices would come under the iot
umbrella and have you ever wondered
about sitting at home having a wi-fi
having all of these devices even a smart
tv if you will connected to the wi-fi
and have you ever questioned how a
hacker would then be able to access your
home through all of these devices record
information and
basically just spy on you similarly an
organization where they're utilizing iot
they would be vulnerable for the same
vulnerabilities and this course does
include iot security to a certain extent
where we talked about vulnerabilities
and how to identify those
vulnerabilities in iot then there's a
new vulnerability analysis module where
it gives you risk assessment it talks
about cvss scoring systems it talks
about how to do a vulnerability
management program in the first place
what are the steps required in a world
liberty management program how should it
be reputable and how it should be
measurable as a program and what should
be the outcome so basically it will give
you a structured way of how to do a
vulnerability management assessment and
how do you want to achieve the end goal
thus leading you to a penetration test
so all the modules are leveled up what
do you mean by leveled up that means
they've been updated to the latest tools
latest standards latest technologies so
you've got cryptographic attacks you
have got attacks on applications like
sql injection we will be talking about
packet sniffing using uh various tools
all of these are upgraded which means
they are up to the latest operating
system so even when we do this course
you will be looking at operating systems
like windows 10 windows 8 windows server
2012 windows server 2016 kali linux
machines android machines and ubuntu
desktop as well so all of the operating
systems are latest the tools are latest
and you will be interacting with these
tools and then there is a mobile
security toolkit as well which will help
you do a penetration test on a mobile
device so these are what is new in
version 10. now let's talk about the
roles and responsibilities that ethical
hacker should have when they actually go
into the world now what are the
responsibilities rules what are the
capabilities that we should have that we
should be able to look at scripts that
would test for vulnerability so for
example a sequel injection attack it's a
script-based attack let's say a
cross-site scripting attack that is
again going to be a script-based attack
so we uh maybe we want to go ahead a
little bit look at windows systems and
do a powershell attack and know about
partial scripting a little bit if you
look at linux windows there's a bash
shell where there's bash scripting and
you'll want to learn that scripting as
well now the course doesn't include all
these scripting languages it does help
you understand what these scripting
languages are and it does have some
basic introduction to how these
languages can be utilized to create
those scripts then we also want to
develop tools to increase security you
want to look at those commands that are
utilized on all operating systems you
want to look at the capabilities of the
operating systems of how to create
security parameters and ensure the
operating systems and applications
devices are secure you should be able to
perform risk assessment now when you say
risk assessment risk assessment is the
likelihood of an attack being actually
executed on an organization based on the
threats and the vulnerabilities that we
have identified so risk assessment is
something that you find out of
vulnerability and then you try to figure
out in a hypothetical manner of what is
the likelihood of that vulnerability
being exploited by a hacker if they find
that vulnerability and if they do
execute that what is the impact that is
going to happen on the organization and
what is the penalties or the
repercussions that the organization is
going to face if that vulnerability is
exploited that's what a risk assessment
is then we should also be able to
develop security policies or set up
security policies and implement them to
ensure that the security mechanisms are
standardized and are consistent and then
we should also look at training staff
for network security to ensure that they
are aware of these vulnerabilities and
they know what their responsibilities
are to maintain some semblance of
security in the organization so why do
we want to become a certified ethical
hacker now since you're watching this
video it's easy to assume that we all
are interested in security we all are
interested in hacking but hacking is not
a real job for us to get a job in the
industry on a security parameter or
information security parameter we want
to become a certified ethical hacker so
if you look at the popular hacking cases
that have happened in 1990s there was a
national crackdown on criminals
microsoft nt operating system was hacked
now this was back in the 90s when
security wasn't that much evolved and
there were a lot of attacks back then
that crippled infrastructure that
crippled banks when they started
realizing that computing isn't as easy
as it seems of course if you use a
computer the functionality is always
there but if the functionality is not
properly configured you're just exposing
yourself to cyber criminals where
they're going to steal information and
your organization may just go bankrupt
because of that in 2013 an example adobe
reported 2.9 million accounts as stolen
in 2016 kaspersky which is a internet
security firm uh announced that there
was 758
million malicious attacks that occurred
worldwide imagine that 758 million
malicious attacks that were identified
and reported in 2018 facebook reported a
loss of 30 millions to accounts that
were stolen 2018 again quora reported
100 million customer accounts being
stolen and in 2018 again marriott 500
million travelers accounts stolen and
manipulated now when you say account for
stolen how does it affect the
organizations now first and foremost if
those accounts were stolen that means
usernames and passwords were cracked and
those accounts may have contained credit
card information or may have contained
some personal information that would
identify the personal
the person and does make them gullible
for a social engineering attack or an
identity theft attack so it has a
cascading effect if i would have been
affected or you would have been affected
with these attacks the repercussions
would have been catastrophic your credit
card information being stolen that means
somebody else would have misused it and
you would have
seen a huge bill come to you come your
way now you can go back to the bank and
uh dispute that but that that's again uh
a dispute that you're trying to uh have
with the bank for something that you
didn't do which requires a lot of energy
and a lot of time and at the end of it
somebody has to pay for that particular
loss now in this scenario the bank would
have had to bear the loss but then
that's a loss for the bank and bank
doesn't want to do that and that's where
they would try to hire certified ethical
hackers who would try to test these
vulnerabilities and plug them in so that
the end consumer is also secured the
bank is also secure right in this case
uh marriott there were 500 million
travelers accounts that were stolen a
lot of credit card information
was
leaked out email email accounts were
hacked and compromised and thus there
was a lot of replication that happened
now the thing is that there are also
laws that these organizations need to
adhere to that tell the organizations
how to keep their information secure and
also have penalties in place if the
organization gets hacked and the
penalties are pretty severe so
organizations do not want to get hacked
or do not want to get compromised not
only from the customers perspective
where they would be losing customers
losing reputations and then thus facing
losses but also from a legislative
perspective where they would have to pay
fines to the government for the frauds
that have happened so
these are some of the popular hacking
cases that have cost these organizations
quite a lot of money
and does
they have a lot of security in mind uh
if you look at the news uh in bbc news
there was something reported from a
french
police that there was a virus that
infected more under 850 000 computers
worldwide now on the similar lines if
you'll remember ransomwares and if you
look at wannacry that happened in 2018
or 2017 it also cost the world four
billion dollars in losses during that
just one small month of its infection
then apple google basically disclosed
that a large scale hacking effort was
targeted at apple devices and this has
been uh it has reported that there was a
sustained effort to hack high iphones
over a period of at least two years
which means that there's a specific
target towards apple consumers and they
are at a higher risk of getting hacked
than others then the texas government
organizations hit by ransomware attack
so hackers have infected 23
organizations connected to local
government in the u.s state of texas
with ransomware that means that their
databases have been encrypted the
government themselves do not have access
to that database the databases could
have been compromised by the hackers and
that means that whatever services were
being provided to the users based on
that database may no longer be available
to the end users because of the
ransomware now
moving on with these why won't do we
want to become a certified ethical
hacker increase the tax lead to more job
openings now if you look at ransomware
the monaco attack that happened in 2017
there was a knee-jerk reaction given by
the rest of the world for i.t security
suddenly budgets all started opening up
suddenly people wanted more ethical
hackers on their payrolls to test for
vulnerabilities in uk and europe we have
gdpr which is again another law that
imposes cv of penalties on organizations
that get hacked and for not having
proper security and a voluntary
assessment and penetration testing
program in place so that leads to a lot
of job requirements as well where
organizations look at people with this
special skill set to help them mitigate
the vulnerabilities to keep to safeguard
them and their customers from hackers
and also from penalties from law
enforcement and governments so does the
demand keeps on increasing for ethical
hackers which automatically means that
the salaries are going to increase as
well so more the demand lesser the
supply higher the salaries that's plain
economics then challenge hacker with
malicious intent so from ethical hackers
perspective it is our duty to safeguard
an organization which means that will be
pitched against hackers and we have to
ensure that those hackers would be
challenged to the maximum limit before
they even try to get access to any of
the resources that we are trying to
protect it offers a boost in your career
so more uh efforts that you put in more
vulnerabilities that you find the better
the career prospects that you have and
the better job aspects that you're going
to get and this also lets you keep
yourself updated on the latest
technology as the technology progresses
as we evolve on technology security will
also evolve and the ethical hacker would
need to keep themselves updated on these
technologies so this is what is a plus
point to become a certified ethical
hacker with the increase in the number
of cyber crimes across the globe there
is also an increase in the number of
cyber security jobs and the role of an
ethical hacker tops the list hi guys
this is shruti from simply learn and
today i will run you through this video
on ethical hacking career so let's get
started and explore the world of ethical
hacking let's begin with a few facts did
you know that by the year 2021 there
will be 3.5 million cyber security job
openings that is a huge number isn't it
and also according to the u.s bureau of
labor statistics there will be 20
increase in the number of jobs from 2016
to 2026 for information security
analysts which includes ethical hackers
this proves that there is a great demand
for ethical hackers at the moment as i
mentioned earlier the number of cyber
crimes across the world will increase as
the digital era will only continue to
grow organizations will be on the
lookout to hire professionals who can
fight these cyber crimes and protect the
company's data and to fight these cyber
crimes we will require individuals who
can think like a hacker and who is that
well to do this job we have ethical
hackers as you might be knowing an
ethical hacker is trained to discover
system vulnerabilities an ethical hacker
is also known as a white hat hacker he
or she is given authorization from the
company to perform security assessments
and at the end an ethical hacker would
have to report the findings back to the
company so that the vulnerabilities can
be fixed an ethical hacker performs
these security assessments with the help
of various hacking techniques and tools
let's now move on to our next topic that
is the steps to become an ethical hacker
you might wonder how to start your
ethical hacking career right well i will
take you through that step by step
firstly the candidate must have a
computer science or an information
technology bachelor's degree it is also
possible to become an ethical hacker
without these degrees but provided you
have the required skill sets and
experience the next requirement to be an
ethical hacker is that the candidate
must have a minimum of two years of
experience in the information security
field you have to start your career with
a software or a networking job and only
then can you move on to the ethical
hacking field you have to start your
career with a software or a networking
job and only then can you move into the
ethical hacking field coming to the
certifications it is necessary for the
candidate to hold various cyber security
certifications certifications play a
vital role in the field of cyber
security your job opportunities can
solely depend on these certifications to
become an ethical hacker you can start
off with the foundational level
certifications such as the ccna and
comptria security plus certifications
finally the last step to become an
ethical hacker is to clear the certified
ethical hacker examination ch
certification is provided by the ec
council it trains the candidate to
protect a company's network by using the
same tools and methods that a hacker
would use the ch exam will have a
duration of 4 hours with 125 number of
questions
if the candidate clears this exam then
he or she will become a certified
ethical hacker now that you know the
steps to become an ethical hacker let's
look into the skill sets which are
required to help you achieve these steps
first and foremost an ethical hacker
needs to have an in-depth knowledge of
the working of the operating systems
knowledge of windows linux and macintosh
operating systems is required for
penetration testing creating exploits
and bug hunting programming will be
important so knowledge of programming
languages such as cec plus plus html
python and php will be very helpful
basic knowledge of networking tcp
protocols and osi model is necessary as
networking is the foundation of cyber
security for securing databases
knowledge of sql nosql postgresql is
necessary cryptography is used to secure
information it is the process of
converting data from a readable format
to a non-readable format and vice versa
cryptanalysis is decryption without a
secret key in most cases certified
ethical hacker would need to perform
cryptanalysis hence ethical hacker has
to be comfortable with cryptography and
cryptanalysis ethical hackers should be
proficient in network security control
measures such as intrusion detection and
intrusion prevention techniques now
let's move on to the responsibilities
which are taken care of by an ethical
hacker let's have a look at these
responsibilities an ethical hacker is
responsible for scanning systems open
and closed ports using tools like nessus
and nmap vulnerabilities and threats are
identified by doing this in addition to
scanning for vulnerabilities they also
search the deep corners of the network
to spot critical information such as
passwords which can make the
organization vulnerable to an attack in
addition to building and maintaining ids
ips and firewalls they also try to evade
these security measures to gauge the
performance of the systems a lot of
times a company's online fraud or online
theft incidents are looked into by an
ethical hacker an ethical hacker also
checks for sniffing networks and
hijacked web servers and applications
those were the responsibilities of an
ethical hacker now let's look into the
various job roles an ethical hacker can
apply for it is a misconception that an
ethical hacker will perform only
penetration testing well there are a
number of other jobs an ethical hacker
can apply for the different job roles
such as that of a penetration tester
information security analyst security
consultant and an information security
manager let's have a look at each of
these job roles one by one a penetration
tester performs the typical
responsibility of an ethical hacker that
is he or she tries to exploit a security
system's vulnerabilities this is carried
out using different hacking tools and
techniques an ethical hacker can also
apply for the role of an information
security analyst there is a difference
between the job rules of a penetration
tester and that of an information
security analyst here the candidate will
be required to primarily design and
protect the organization's network from
various cyber attacks finally the
candidate is also required to document
the identified security breaches so that
it can be omitted the next time the
responsibilities of a security
consultant is more or less similar to
that of an information security analyst
that we saw previously as a security
consultant you will be responsible to
design implement and maintain barrier
security architectures in addition to
this you're also required to upgrade the
security systems as and when required
finally an ethical hacker can also apply
to the role of an information security
manager as the name suggests this role
will require the candidate to possess
managerial skills as an information
security manager is responsible to help
the it and the information security team
now that we have seen the
responsibilities the skills and the
steps to become an ethical hacker let's
have a look at the different companies
hiring ethical hackers to name a few we
have bank of america ernest and young
kpmg urban pro and ibm let's now look
into the salary structure of an ethical
hacker well in india the average annual
salary of a certified ethical hacker is
nearly 4 lakhs 76 000 rupees and in the
us the average annual salary of a
certified ethical hacker is 91 000
now i will guide you through a sample
resume of a penetration tester as you
can see on your screens this is a sample
resume of a penetration tester we will
look into this resume closely and
understand how your resume should look
like if you are applying for the role of
a penetration tester as always you can
start off with your name and your email
id and your phone number followed by a
brief summary of your current job
profile it is prefer to add your
linkedin profile link here and also your
github profile link if you have one as i
mentioned earlier this is a sample
resume for a penetration tester and
hence we have to have more than two
years of experience in the information
security field as you can see under the
experience section the candidate has two
prior experiences out of which the first
experience is that of a software tester
and second is that of a penetration
tester you would have to mention your
latest or current experience at the
beginning you can mention your job role
and the company and the duration under
which you can list out the various
responsibilities that you are looking
into currently if you are a penetration
tester you can mention responsibilities
such as security monitoring black box
testing documentation of the results
vulnerability scanning and so on below
this you can mention your first
company's experience with the roles and
responsibilities that you have performed
earlier here the candidate was a
software tester before becoming a
penetration tester let's move on to the
education section here the candidate
holds a bachelor's degree in computer
science you can mention your degree
followed by the university name or if
you're applying for any other role in
the cyber security domain it is
recommended that you list out the
certifications as well to start off with
a ccna certification will be preferred
followed by a certified ethical hacker
certification which is a must if you are
applying for the role of a penetration
tester in addition to it the certified
expert penetration tester certification
will also hold a great advantage after
mentioning the certifications you can go
ahead and mention your skill sets here
we have the technical skills and
non-technical skills under technical
skills you can mention the programming
languages that you know here we have c c
plus plus java perl you can also mention
the operating systems that you have
worked on for example windows linux unix
and in addition to the programming
languages and the os you can also
mention the tools that you know such as
nmap metasploit tools which will be
helpful if you are applying for the role
of a penetration tester then you can
also mention encryption technologies
knowledge of sql and bug tracking
systems if you have worked on them
before if you have participated in a
code authored you can mention that here
as well under the non-technical skills
you can mention various competitions
that you have taken part in and the
games that you like and other
extracurricular activities finally you
can also mention the projects undertaken
under the projects undertaken you can
talk about the various projects that you
have performed in your company or
outside the company here we have two
projects one as a software test engineer
and second one as a penetration tester
so this is how a resume of a penetration
tester will look like let us understand
the importance of the ca certification
before getting to know about its content
so why should you take up the ch version
11. the certified ethical hacker is the
most trusted ethical hacking
certification and a recommended one by
employers around the globe
since the introduction of the ca
certification in 2003 it is globally
recognized as a standard within the
information security field the ch
version 11 by ec council continues to
keep up to the standard and it
familiarizes the latest hacking
techniques and teaches you advanced
hacking tools and exploits used the ch
version 11 aligns with the current cyber
security market requirements and adds
the latest advancements in the
cybersecurity field
the ca certification helps and trains
you to think like a hacker and this in
turn helps you beat a hacker and defend
your network after obtaining the ca
certification you'll be a certified
ethical hacker a certified ethical
hacker is a skilled professional working
in a red team environment who safeguards
networks and understands attack
strategies and mimics the skills of
malicious hackers certified ethical
hackers discover vulnerabilities in a
system and operate with permission from
the system owners only
so who can become a certified ethical
hacker and who can take up the ca
certification let us have a look at that
now
in the first case to be eligible for the
ca certification exam you need to attend
the official training from authorized
easy council training partners it can be
an online training or tutor-led training
from ec council learning partners only
then are you eligible to take up the ca
certification exam
so a candidate who has completed an
official ec council training is eligible
to take up the exam without going
through the application process
or in the second case in order to be
considered for this credential you need
to have at least two years of work
experience in the information security
domain and you must pay a non-refundable
application fee and submit an
eligibility application form
once it is approved you can take up the
ch exam
after the application is approved you
can purchase the test voucher
in the latest version of the ceh we will
see the addition of various core
concepts moving on to our next topic let
us see how different the ch version 11
is and few of its objectives
firstly it outlines ethical hacking
concepts cyber kill chain concepts and
overview of information security and
various laws and regulations related to
information security this certification
briefs you about the faces of system
hacking attacking techniques and how you
can maintain access
it also briefs you about footprinting
concepts and ways of utilizing
footprinting tools along with necessary
countermeasures
the next objective is to familiarize
with vulnerability assessment along with
a hands-on experience of various
scanning tools
next we have cybersecurity threats like
malware threats analysis of various
worms viruses and trojans various
malware concepts packets sniffing
concepts and techniques have been
introduced into this domain
it also highlights the concepts related
to social engineering denial of service
attacks sql injection and aviation
techniques
it also speaks about wireless hacking
concepts and mobile device management
the concept of operational technology is
a new addition this time
next is getting acquainted with security
solutions like firewalls honeypots ips
their evasion and protection
our fifth point is knowing various
topics in cryptography like encryption
algorithms public key infrastructure and
cryptanalysis
moving on the next objective is to
incorporate padded security os as it
offers better performance on lower
powered laptops and machines when
compared to kali linux
next is to learn to recognize and deal
with iot based vulnerabilities and
attacks with the ch version 11 course
that covers the latest iot hacking tools
you would be required to ensure the
safety of iot devices
our next point is with respect to the
evolving cloud industry you would need
to learn how to identify and defend
cloud-based threats and attacks
the latest version of ch includes new
operating systems and windows 10
configured with domain controller and
vulnerable web applications for
improving hacking skills
finally what is different is that more
than 50 percent of the ch version 11
course is dedicated to practical skills
in live ranges by our ec council labs ec
council leads in this aspect of the
industry now that we saw the ch exam
objectives let us look into the ch exam
topics we teach
as you see on your screens this is a pie
chart with nine domains in ch along with
their weightages
you can prepare for your exam
accordingly
let us move on and take a closer look at
each of these domains their respective
subdomains and their descriptions
our first domain is information security
and ethical hacking overview
this domain consists of questions from
information security cyber kill chain
concepts ethical hacking concepts
various hacking concepts and information
security laws and standards
you can expect a total number of eight
questions from this domain the weightage
of this section is six percent
the second domain is reconnaissance
techniques under the subdomains we have
footprinting and reconnaissance at first
this covers various topics like
footprinting concepts footprinting
methodology email footprinting
footprinting through web services dns
footprinting footprinting through social
engineering etc
the next subdomain in this section is
scanning networks
scanning networks covers various
concepts like scanning tools host
discovery port and service discovery os
discovery draw network diagrams scanning
beyond ids firewall etc
and our third subdomain under
reconnaissance techniques is enumeration
various topics like snmp enumeration ntp
and nfs enumeration smtp and dns
enumeration and enumeration
countermeasures are covered under this
subdomain a total of 26 questions will
be asked from this domain under
footprinting and reconnaissance you will
have 10 questions and under scanning
networks and other 10 and finally under
enumeration you will have 6 questions a
total weightage of 21
is given to this particular topic
our third domain is system hacking faces
and attack techniques
under our third domain our first sub
domain is about vulnerability analysis
this subdomain covers topics on
vulnerability assessment vulnerability
classification vulnerability assessment
solutions and tools and various
vulnerability assessment reports our
next sub domain is about system hacking
you have concepts like gaining access
cracking passwords vulnerability
exploitation escalating privileges
maintaining access covered under this
subdomain and finally we have malware
threads under this domain malware
threads incorporate concepts like apt
concepts trojan concepts virus and worm
concepts malware analysis and so on a
total of 21 questions will be asked from
this domain
under vulnerability analysis there will
be nine questions asked system hacking
and other six questions and finally
under malware threats you will have six
other questions asked
that sums up to a total 21 with a
weightage of 17 for this domain
our fourth domain is about network and
perimeter hacking
here you have various subdomains and one
of it is social engineering under social
engineering you will be asked questions
based on social engineering techniques
insider threats impersonation on social
networking sites identity theft and so
on you'll also have various question on
the sniffing concepts as it is another
subdomain
you can also expect questions from the
denial of service subdomain here
questions related to botnets and ddos
attacks will be asked various session
hijacking concepts are another crucial
part of this domain the final sub domain
is about evading ids firewalls and
honeypots
here various concepts on ids ips
firewall and honeypots are covered you
will need to understand how to evade ids
and firewalls and how to detect
honeypots
a total number of 18 questions will be
asked from the fourth domain that was
network and perimeter hacking and the
weightage for this domain is 14
our fifth domain is about web
application hacking and our first
subdomain in it is hacking web servers
this incorporates concepts related to
web server attacks web server attack
tools patch management and so on
the next sub domain is about hacking web
applications here you have various
concepts related to bypass client-side
controls analyze web applications
footprint web infrastructure attack
access controls and how to perform
injection attacks and so on
finally under the sql injection
subdomain you will have questions based
on sql injection the types of sql
injection the sql injection methodology
sql injection tools aviation techniques
and sql injection counter measures
here a total of 20 questions will be
asked from this domain
and that is a weightage of 16 percent
will be given to the web application
hacking domain
our six domain is solely devoted to
wireless network hacking
this domain focuses on hacking wireless
networks various wireless concepts
wireless encryption wireless threats
wireless hacking tools various hacking
methodologies bluetooth hacking and
wireless counter measures are covered a
total of eight questions will be asked
from this domain with a weightage of six
percent
our seventh domain is all about mobile
platform iot and ot hacking our first
sub domain here is hacking mobile
platforms
here the concepts that are touched upon
are mobile platform attack vectors
hacking android os hacking ios mobile
device management and mobile security
guidelines and tools
our next subdomain here is about iot and
ot hacking which covers concepts on iot
hacking tools its methodologies counter
measures and it also speaks about ot
concepts ot attacks ot hacking tools and
ot counter measures
you have a total of 10 questions asked
from this domain with a weightage of 8
percent the next domain is very
interesting and it is all related to
cloud the cloud computing domain covers
concepts based on cloud computing
serverless computing cloud computing
threats cloud hacking and cloud security
the weightage given to this domain is
six percent with the total number of
questions of seven and finally we have
cryptography as our ninth domain
as the name suggests this domain covers
topics based on cryptography concepts
encryption algorithms cryptography tools
public key infrastructure email
encryption disk encryption cryptanalysis
and counter measures
and seven questions will be asked from
this domain with a weightage of six
percent now that you saw the ch exam
topic's weightage let us have a closer
look at the ch exam details
let us first have a look at the ch exam
based on mcqs
the exam title is certified ethical
hacker with the exam code of 312-50
this exam will have 125 questions with a
time limit of 4 hours the test format is
multiple choice questions
the pass percentage varies ideally
between 60 to 85 percent now let's have
a look at the ch practical exam details
in order to gain the ch master
recognition it is mandatory that you
take up the ch practical exam as well
the exam title is certified ethical
hacker practical and this practical exam
will have 20 questions with the duration
of 6 hours
the exam format will be ilab cyber range
and finally the passing score for the ch
practical exam is at 70
after clearing both the mcq based exam
and the practical exam you can get the
ch master recognition now that we had a
look at the ch exam details let us have
a look at the career prospects for a
professional with this certification
having the ch certification guarantees
that you have an insight into the
hacking world hence companies want to
hire professionals who can think like a
hacker and safeguard their networks and
systems
a candidate with the ca certification
can apply for various cybersecurity job
roles such as penetration tester
security engineer and information
security analyst from the long list
according to pay scale the annual
average salary of a ch professional in
india is rupees 5 lakhs per annum
meanwhile in the united states a
professional holding the ca
certification earns nearly 93 000 on an
average basis annually now that you had
a look at the ch version 11
certification and its career prospects
what are you waiting for get certified
with simply learn and back that ca
certification when we hear the term
hacker we may picture a dangerous cyber
criminal however not all hackers are
inherently bad they are powerful
individuals who use their technical
skills to break into computer networks
and bypass security measures
hacking is not always bad and it is to
be noted that the world of computers is
actually safer to an extent because of a
particular type of hacker
a hacker is deemed to be good or bad
depending on their motive and whether or
not they are breaking the law in this
video we will acquaint you with the
differences between a white hat hacker
black hat hacker and a grey attacker
through a short story
hackers are basically categorized by the
type of metaphorical hat they don't
white hat grey hat and black hat
hackers can either be a black hat or a
white hat or a grey hat
hackers can be good or bad depending on
which color hat they decide to wear and
by this we mean they're hacking motifs
and obviously not in the sense of
creating a fashion statement here
let's have a look at our story
our story here revolves around dan who
is the owner of a company that provides
a platform for video conferencing
his platform enables online
communication for video meetings audio
meetings and webinars
just like other video conferencing
platforms his platform too has built-in
features like chat recording screen
sharing and so on
everything went well and his business
increased tremendously with the onset of
the covet 19 pandemic
covert 19 accelerated the rise of the
worldwide digital economy and it made
people rapidly adopt video conferencing
tools and apps
in a contactless world starting from
employee interactions to family
get-togethers to virtual workout classes
everything happened virtually dance
video conferencing platform enabled
long-distance communication and enhanced
collaboration
so now you might be wondering what could
have gone wrong well there are many
risks involved when it comes to the
safety of these online platforms
online meeting rooms are susceptible to
a number of digital threats
dan received complaints from his
customers that his platform was insecure
and safe anymore
little did dan know that the popularity
of his video conferencing platform made
hackers eager to disrupt the virtual
meetings and hijack the conferences
his platform witnessed complaints like
the addition of an unknown participant
in every meeting room someone covering
up information that is being presented
and also unknown screen recording of a
meeting to name a few
these intruders were sneaky hackers who
tried to gain access to sensitive
information and who tried to disrupt
meetings
and how did these hackers manage to do
all this
well this was done by exploiting
weaknesses in dance computer network in
order to obtain unauthorized access to
crucial data and sensitive information
this is known as hacking and the
individuals who carry this out are known
as hackers
in this form of hacking that dan
witnessed hackers exploited dan's
company's security posture by
identifying weaknesses in it in order to
intrude into the meetings and gain
access to business data or personal data
and this form of hacking is definitely
bad and unethical the hackers who
carried this against dance company are
known as black hat hackers
these hackers are cyber criminals who
carry out cyber attacks with a negative
intention
these attacks can be in the form of
trojan virus malware attacks phishing
attacks ddos attacks man in the middle
attacks sequel injection attacks and so
on
so who exactly is a black hat hacker
like in the case of dance organizations
cyber attack
black hat hackers are highly skilled
cyber criminals who break into computer
systems and networks with malicious
intent
they illegally hack into a system and
this is obviously without the system
owners approval
such hackers do not abide by the loss
they violate laws and disrupt networks
the motive behind these attacks vary
from monetary gains to personal profit
usually they are for monetary gains
black hat hackers may violate the
confidentiality integrity or
availability of a company's systems and
data they may also use malware to
destroy files or steal passwords credit
card numbers and other confidential
information
black hat hackers are also sometimes
called crackers
so this is who a black hat hacker is
moving back to dan's story
black hat hackers disrupted his business
and he lost his customers as nobody
wished to communicate on an unsecure
platform
it is but true right would you be okay
to use a platform that is unsafe
none of us want to have unknown people
in our meetings right this is how dan's
customers felt too and this news spread
and his company's reputation took a bad
hit
that is when ted approached dan so who
is dead let's have a look at that now
ted who was unknown to dan explained to
him that he found dan's network to be
weak
ted told dan that he has identified
vulnerabilities in dance systems and
networks and he will fix them provided
dan pays him well
dan had nothing to lose and without any
further delay he paid ted a good amount
of money to fix the vulnerabilities in
dance networks
on receiving the money ted began his
work and he fixed all the issues and
vulnerabilities in dan's network he made
sure that nobody can exploit dance
network vulnerabilities again and this
way he safeguarded dan's network for the
time being
so who is dead
well he's called a grey hat hacker as
they say not all things are black and
white so is the concept of grey hat
hackers as fascinating as the name
sounds let us dive deep into
understanding the role of a gray hat
hacker a grey hat is a security expert
who may at times violate the laws or the
ethical standards
however they do not carry a malicious
intent unlike a black hat hacker
hence they are known to work both
defensively and offensively
they land between the good and the bad
gray hat hackers look for
vulnerabilities in a system without
permission but with good intentions
just like how ted informed dan about how
he could exploit dan's system
vulnerabilities greyhound hackers inform
an organization the same and in return
ask for a fee to fix it
in some cases when the organization
doesn't comply gray hat hackers may
become black hat hackers
although a grey hat hacker's intention
might not be bad what they do is still
illegal since they do not have
permission to break into another system
back to our story
although dance issue was sorted by ted
for the time being he had a few concerns
[Music]
his first concern was history repeating
itself yes he was worried about what if
black hat hackers hack into his systems
again
although his system vulnerabilities are
fixed at the moment it was a matter of
time before they could be exploited
again with new hacking techniques
his next thought was to have a
professional who could constantly keep a
tab on his networks and protect it from
hackers don't you think his concerns
were justified yes it was as this was
the only way he could provide a safe and
secure video conferencing platform in
the long run
that is when dan's friend came to his
rescue and introduced and the ethical
hacker to him
and being an ethical hacker assured dan
that she would scan and identify his
network for system vulnerabilities
before an outsider exploits it and she
would fix those vulnerabilities on a
regular basis
such ethical hackers like anne are
called white attackers
now that we saw who black hat hackers
and grey hat hackers were it is time we
learn about our third type of hacker who
is a white attacker
a white hat hacker gains access to
networks with an intention to fix the
identified weaknesses
they also perform penetration testing
and vulnerability assessments and break
into systems with permission
they search for loopholes or
vulnerabilities in any given piece of
technology just like how a black hat
hacker would do
however white hat hackers harden their
organization system before the bad guy
can get in
their goal is to spot system and network
vulnerabilities in order to improve
system security white hat hackers are
also known as ethical hackers since they
obey the law of the land and follow a
code of ethics
many companies and government
organizations employ white hat hackers
to help them secure their systems
[Music]
these hackers are typically hired by
organizations to look for
vulnerabilities in a system like other
hackers the only difference being they
are given permission to break in
once dan spots the vulnerabilities she
documents her findings and gives dan
advice on how to fix them or she'll even
take it up to fix them so that an
outsider cannot spot it in the future
anne does this on a regular basis as
system updates happen regularly and it
is imperative to be on track with it and
fix new vulnerabilities
this made sure dan's network is now safe
and secure
gradually he regained his customers
trust and his platform got back to being
one of the best and safest platforms for
video conferencing
this resulted in a huge business growth
and dan was very happy
just like how ann put an end to dance
business problems there are many white
hat hackers out there who are in great
demand by organizations to safeguard
their networks from cyber attacks
and if you are interested in a career in
ethical hacking then simply learn can
help you fulfill your dreams
simply learn ch version 11 certification
provides you the hands-on training
required to master the techniques
hackers use to penetrate network systems
and fortify your system against it
this ethical hacking course is aligned
with the latest ch version 11 by ec
council and will adequately prepare you
to increase your blue team skills
so what are you waiting for get
certified with simply learn and become a
certified ethical hacker and put an end
to the cyber crimes in the world
remember the more active white hat
hackers are the fewer opportunities
black hat hackers have for system
exploitation
we humans are highly tech savvy in
today's times
with the extensive use of the internet
and modern technologies there is a
massive challenge in protecting all our
digital data such as net banking
information account credentials and
medical reports to name a few have you
heard about the deadly wannacry
ransomware attack
the attack happened in may 2017 in asia
and then it spread across the world
within a day more than 230 000 computers
were infected across 150 countries
the wannacry cryptoworm encrypted the
data and locked the users out of their
systems
for decryption of the data the users
were asked for a ransom of 300 to 600 in
bitcoin
the users who used the unsupported
version of microsoft windows and those
who hadn't installed the security update
of april 2017 were targeted in this
attack
the wannacry attack took a toll on every
sector top tier organizations like
hitachi nissan and fedex had to put
their businesses on hold as their
systems were affected too
now this is what you call a cyber attack
to prevent such attacks cyber security
is implemented we can define cyber
security as the practice of protecting
networks programs computer systems and
their components from unauthorized
digital attacks
these illegal attacks are often referred
to as hacking
hacking refers to exploiting weaknesses
in a computer network to obtain
unauthorized access to information a
hacker is a person who tries to hack
into computer systems
this is a misconception that hacking is
always wrong there are hackers who work
with different motives
let's have a look at three different
types of hackers
black hat hackers are individuals who
illegally hack into a system for
monetary gain on the contrary we have
white hat hackers who exploit the
vulnerabilities in a system by hacking
into it with permission in order to
defend the organization this form of
hacking is absolutely legal and ethical
hence they are also often referred to as
ethical hackers
in addition to these hackers we also
have the grey hat hackers as the name
suggests the color gray is a blend of
both white and black these hackers
discover vulnerabilities in a system and
report it to the system's owner which is
a good act
but they do this without seeking the
owner's approval
sometimes grey hat hackers also ask for
money in return for the spotted
vulnerabilities
now that you have seen the different
types of hackers let's understand more
about the hacking that is legal and
valid ethical hacking through an
interesting story dan runs a trading
company he does online training with the
money his customers invest everything
was going well and dan's business was
booming until a hacker decided to hack
the company's servers
the hacker stole the credentials of
various trading accounts he asked for a
lump sum ransom in exchange for the
stolen credentials dan took the hacker's
words lightly and didn't pay the hacker
as a result the hacker withdrew money
from various customers accounts and dan
was liable to pay back the customers
dan lost a lot of money and also the
trust of his customers
after this incident dan gave a lot of
thought as to what could have gone wrong
with the security infrastructure in his
company he wished there was someone from
his company who could have run a test
attack to see how vulnerable systems
were before the hacker penetrated into
the network
this was when he realized he needed an
employee who thinks like a hacker and
identifies the vulnerabilities in his
network before an outsider does
to do this job he hired an ethical
hacker john
john was a skilled professional who
worked precisely like a hacker in no
time he spotted several vulnerabilities
in dan's organization and closed all the
loopholes
hiring an ethical hacker helped dan
protect his customers from further
attacks in the future
this in turn increased the company's
productivity and guarded the company's
reputation
so now you know hacking is not always
bad
john in this scenario expose the
vulnerabilities in the existing network
and such hacking is known as ethical
hacking ethical hacking is distributed
into six different phases let us look at
these faces step by step with respect to
how john our ethical hacker will act
before launching an attack the first
step john takes is to gather all the
necessary information about the
organization's system that he intends to
attack this step is called
reconnaissance he uses tools like nmap
and h-ping for this purpose
john then tries to spot the
vulnerabilities if any in the target
system using tools like nmap and expose
this is the scanning phase
now that he has located the
vulnerabilities he then tries to exploit
them
this step is known as gaining access
after john makes his way through the
organization's networks he tries to
maintain his access for future attacks
by installing back doors in the target
system
the metasploit tool helps him with this
this phase is called maintaining access
john is a brilliant hacker hence he
tries his best not to leave any evidence
of his attack
this is the fifth phase clearing tracks
we now have the last phase that is
reported
in this phase john documents a summary
of his entire attack the vulnerabilities
he spotted
the tools he used and the success rate
of the attack
looking into the report dan is now able
to take a call and see how to protect
his organization from any external cyber
attacks
don't you all think john is an asset to
any organization if you want to become
an ethical hacker like john
then there are a few skills that you
need to acquire
first and foremost you need to have a
good knowledge of operating environments
such as windows linux unix and macintosh
you must have reasonably good knowledge
of programming languages such as html
php python sql and javascript networking
is the base of ethical hacking hence you
should be good at it ethical hackers
should be well aware of security laws so
that they don't misuse their skills
finally you must have a global
certification on ethical hacking to
successfully bag a position of an
ethical hacker like john
few examples of ethical hacking
certification are certified ethical
hacker certification ceh comptia pentest
plus
and licensed penetration tester
certification to name a few
simply learn provides a cyber security
expert masters program that will equip
you with all the skills required by a
cyber security expert you could have a
look at it by clicking the link in the
description
the endless growth of technologies in
this area is directly proportional to
the number of cyber crimes
cyber crimes are estimated to cost six
trillion dollars in 2021
hence to tackle these cyber crimes
organizations are continuously on the
lookout for cyber security professionals
the average annual salary of a certified
ethical hacker is 91 000 in the u.s and
approximately rupees 7 lakhs in india so
what are you waiting for get certified
and become an ethical hacker like john
and put an end to the cyber attacks in
the world in this video we bring you the
top 10 computer hacks of all time let's
see what we have at number 10. from
april 27 2007 estonia the european
country faced a series of cyber attacks
that lasted for weeks
this happened when the estonian
government decided to move the bronze
soldier from talon center to a less
prominent military cemetery located on
the city's outskirts
unprecedented levels of internet traffic
took down estonian banks online services
media outlets broadcasters and
government bodies
botnet sent massive waves of spam and
vast amounts of automated online
requests
according to researchers the public
faced ddos attacks there were conflicts
to edit the english language version of
the bronze soldier's wikipedia page as
well
although there is no confirmation
russia is believed to be behind these
cyber attacks that largely crippled the
estonian society
let's now move on to the next attack on
december 23 2015 several parts of
ukraine witnessed a power outage and
this was not a typical blackout it was
indeed the result of a cyber attack
information systems of three energy
distribution companies in ukraine were
compromised it is the first known
victorious cyber attack on apar grid it
is said that here hackers sent out
phishing emails to the power companies
30 substations were switched off and
about 230 000 people were left in the
dark for about one to six hours us
investigators believed that russia-based
hackers were responsible for this
experts have warned that other countries
could also be vulnerable to such attacks
let's see what we have at number eight
in the year 1999 a cyber attack caused a
21 day shutdown of nasa computers
unbelievable isn't it the hacker was
none other than the then 15 year old
jonathan james he first penetrated u.s
department of defense divisions
computers and installed a back door on
its servers
this allowed him to intercept more than
a thousand government emails including
the ones containing usernames and
passwords
this helped james steal a piece of nasa
software and crack the nasa computers
that support the international space
station which cost the space exploration
agencies 41 000 dollars as systems were
shut down for three weeks
he was the first person to carry out a
computer hack against the american space
agency
let's now move on to the next attack
in late november 2014 there was a leak
of confidential data from the film
studio of sony pictures
information about sony pictures
employees their emails copies of the
then unreleased sony films future
propositions and other crucial data were
leaked
this cyber attack was carried out by a
hacker group named guardians of peace so
what did the hackers want
well they demanded that sony withdraw
its then upcoming movie the interview
this movie was a comedy story line to
assassinate the north korean leader kim
jong-un sony then decided to cancel the
film's theatrical release due to the
threats at cinema screening the movie
it is indeed hard to trace the roots of
a cyber attack in this case after
evaluation the u.s intelligence
officials arrived at the theory that the
attack was in a way related to the
government of north korea
however north korea had denied the same
moving on to our number six
in december 2006 tjx the u.s retailer
company identified that 45.6 million
debit and credit card details were
stolen
this happened from one of its systems
over 18 months by an unknown number of
intruders it was one of the first
largest ever cyber attacks involving the
loss of personal data as a result banks
in the affected regions had to reissue
and block thousands of payment cards a
group of hackers did this albert
gonzalez being the mastermind the group
was from miami the place where the tjx
heist was believed to have originated
reports said that the tjx data breach
occurred because of weak web encryption
at two of its marshall stores in miami
next moving on to our top five let us
see what we have at number five
the year 2010 witnessed the discovery of
the deadly computer worm stuxnet
this malware's motive was unlike any
other usual cyber attacks it aimed at
destructing the equipment the computers
controlled
stuxnet came with the deadly purpose of
damaging iran's nuclear infrastructure
it infected more than 200 000 computers
including 14 industrial sites and a
uranium enrichment plant in iran
stuxnet initially spread via microsoft
windows and targeted siemens industrial
control systems
although it was discovered only in 2010
it is believed to have been silently
sabotaging iran's nuclear facilities
it was one of the first discovered
malware that was capable of hampering
hardware systems it largely damaged the
centrifuge of the iranian reactors this
was believed to be a cyber weapon
created by the us and the israeli
intelligence although there is no
documented evidence or acceptance by
either of the countries for the same
moving on to number four in the year
2014 home depot was the victim of one of
the deadliest cyber attacks 56 million
payment cards were compromised along
with 53 million customer email addresses
stolen
this security breach happened from april
to september 2014.
criminals were believed to have used a
third party vendor's username and
password to enter the perimeter of home
depot network the attackers were then
able to deploy custom built malware on
its self-checkout systems in the us and
canada
moving on to our top three
as you might be aware the playstation
gaming system is one of sony's most
popular products
unfortunately in april 2011 sony
executives witnessed abnormal activity
on the playstation network this resulted
in the compromise of approximately 77
million playstation users accounts and
prevented users of playstation 3 and
playstation portable consoles from
accessing this service
this forced sony to turn off the
playstation network on april 20th on may
4th sony confirmed that personally
identifiable information from each of
the 77 million accounts had been exposed
the outage lasted for 23 days sony
released almost daily announcements
concerning the system outage
in the end sony is believed to have
invested approximately 170 million
dollars to improve the network security
to investigate the attack and to cover
the expenses of caring for the consumers
that had been affected
let's now move on to the next attack at
number two in may 2017 one of the most
dangerous cyber attacks took place
it was known as the wannacry ransomware
attack caused by the wannacry crypto
worm the victims were the users that
used the unsupported version of
microsoft windows and those who hadn't
installed the new security update
this did not take place through fishing
like other attacks but through an
exposed vulnerable smb port
the attack originated in asia and then
eventually spread across the globe in a
day more than 200 000 computers were
infected across 150 countries
the wannacry crypto worm locked the
users out of the targeted systems and
encrypted their data the users were
asked for a ransom of 300 to 600 dollars
which had to be paid via bitcoin in
exchange for their data
this attack took a toll on both private
and government organizations it resulted
in damages from hundreds of millions to
billions of dollars
in a matter of few days the emergency
patches released by microsoft halted the
attack also the discovery of a kill
switch prevented the infected computers
from spreading the crypto worm security
experts in a few countries believed that
north korea was behind this attack and
finally let's see what we have at number
one
more than two decades ago in march 1999
the melissa virus a mass mailing macro
virus was released
it targeted microsoft word and outlook
based systems and created considerable
network traffic
melissa virus infected computers via
emails the email would look like an
important message well yes it was fake
if the recipient opens the attachments
in the mail and downloads the document
and then opens it with microsoft word a
virus was released on their computers
this would then mass mail itself to the
first 50 people in the victims contact
list and then disable multiple safeguard
features on microsoft word and microsoft
outlook this began spreading like a
wildfire across the internet david l
smith released the virus the virus
caused nearly 80 million worth of
damages it did not steal data or money
however it caused a havoc almost 1
million email accounts were disrupted
worldwide agencies were overloaded and
some had to be shut down entirely and
internet traffic in some locations were
slowed down
hacking is a very interesting term that
most of you might have come across
it is a method by which you exploit a
network to gain access to crucial
information
when the art of hacking is used
rightfully you can prevent various cyber
attacks just like how ethical hackers
safeguard our networks
on that note hey guys welcome to yet
another exciting video by simply learn
in this video we bring you the best
programming languages for hacking here
we will give you the top 5 programming
languages that will help you enhance
your hacking skills
but before we begin if you're new here
and haven't subscribed already make sure
to hit the subscribe button and the bell
icon for interesting tech videos every
day so let's get started first let's
understand the importance of knowing
programming for hacking
you might wonder if programming is a
necessity to become a hacker as you
might be aware hacking involves breaking
the protocols and exploiting a network
thus being a hacker requires you to
understand the languages of the software
that you are focusing on
hence it is required that a hacker knows
coding having zero coding knowledge will
definitely limit your opportunities in
the future
knowing different programming languages
is undoubtedly an asset for hackers
everyone wants to become a hacker today
however it is not as easy as it is shown
in numerous movies it takes plenty of
practice and programming knowledge to
become an ethical hacking expert
if you want to become a hacker it is
imperative that you have a knack for
programming languages it is a known fact
that some of the world's best hackers
started off as programmers
if you know how to program you will be
able to dissect a code and analyze it
you can write your scripts or malware
that can be used on the victim yes there
are several ready-made scripts available
today however you might need to apply
your skills in case the available
scripts don't work well for you
sometimes when script modification is
required you should be in a position to
do that in such a scenario zero
knowledge of the respective programming
language will definitely be a hindrance
programs can also help you automate
multiple tasks which would normally take
a lot of time
codes allow you to penetrate different
fields you want to hack
it will help you identify the plan
behind an attack and defend against
deadly hacking techniques and make your
cybersecurity career worthwhile
it will help you understand the working
of the target system or application
before carrying out an exploit
now that we have an idea as to why
programming is important for hackers let
us understand which programming
languages should a hacker learn there
are several programming languages for
hacking and it might be overwhelming to
choose from the endless list
here we are to help you with that
do keep in mind that your choice of
programming language will also depend on
the type of system you are targeting and
your strategy
let us now move on to the list of the
top programming languages that are
extensively used by hackers around the
world
as you see on your screens here we have
the top 5 programming languages for
hackers let us go through them one by
one
number one on our list is one of the
most popular programming languages today
that is python
python is a general purpose programming
language and in the field of hacking it
is mainly used for exploit writing
it is referred to as the de facto
hacking programming language it plays a
crucial role in writing hacking scripts
exploits and malicious programs
one great feature that makes hacking
easy with python is the availability of
ready-made modules
for example os modules are available if
the target is a native operating system
for networking there is a socket module
and a lot more
python socket programming can be used
for discovering vulnerabilities in a
system since python code helps in
checking the security integrity of
systems and it can also be used to
exploit them
python has a massive community that
helps with third party plugins every day
it is also an easy to read language with
a simple syntax this will be helpful for
beginners
you can easily write automation scripts
using python and it also makes
prototyping much faster
moving on to our second programming
language we have javascript
currently javascript is one of the best
programming languages for hacking web
applications
a good understanding of javascript
allows a hacker to discover
vulnerabilities and carry web
exploitation since most of their web
apps use javascript or one of its
libraries
knowing javascript will help you
discover flaws in web applications
javascript can be used to read saved
cookies and security experts also use
javascript to develop cross-site
scripting programs for hacking
javascript is known for carrying out
attacks like cross-site scripting
javascript can also be used to spread
and reproduce malware and viruses easily
initially javascript was a client-side
scripting language however with the
release of node.js it now supports
back-end development this implies a
larger field for exploitation
a hacker can now use javascript to snoop
the type towards inject malicious code
and track browsing history to name a few
number three on our list is php
hypertext preprocessor or php is a
dynamic server-side programming language
that is used to build websites
hackers should understand php as it will
help them understand web hacking
techniques better
especially if you're into web hacking
then getting your hands on php would be
an asset
php is used in server-side scripting
using php you could write a custom
application that modifies settings on a
web server and makes a target server
susceptible to attacks
with the help of php you can also
eliminate any vulnerabilities in your
code
php is one of the most powerful server
side languages used in most of their web
domains
this shows how learning php can help you
with web hacking and also help you fight
against malicious attackers
popular content management systems run
on a foundation of php hence having a
strong knowledge of php can help you
protect or compromise such websites
next on a list of the best programming
languages for hackers is sql
sql is the acronym for structured query
language
although sql is not a traditional
programming language
it is a language used for only
communicating with databases
several systems like mysql postgresql
store their data in databases
sql is used to interact with such
databases in order to organize add
retrieve delete or edit data from a
database
having an in-depth knowledge of sql lets
you comprehend the structure of a
database thereby helping you decide
which scripts or tools to deploy
sql is used for the purpose of web
hacking sql is undoubtedly the best
programming language when it comes to
hacking into a large databases
it will be impossible to contract
database attacks without a good
understanding of sql
using sql hackers can perform an attack
known as sql injection attack such an
attack enables hackers to access
confidential information from databases
sql is used by hackers to develop
various hacking programs based on sql
injection sql injection is used to
bypass web application login algorithms
that are weak
such an attack can also help a hacker
view and modify confidential information
from databases
finally at number 5 we have the c
programming language
it is no surprise that we have c the
mother of all programming languages on
our list
it is used massively in the security
field
it helps with exploit writing and
development
the low-level nature of c provides an
edge over other programming languages
used for hacking
a hacker can use the c programming
language to his or her advantage when it
comes to accessing low-level hardware
components such as the ram
security professionals mostly uc when
they are required to manipulate system
resources and hardware
c also helps penetration testers write
programming scripts
most operating systems and computer
programs are coded in c language hence
learning c you will help hackers get an
overview of the structure of operating
systems
c is also used to create shell codes
root kits exploits build undetectable
malware key loggers and much more
sometimes it is also advisable to learn
both c and c plus plus as they both come
in handy for hackers
so those were our top five programming
languages for hackers do keep in mind
that the most important step of becoming
a hacker is to learn various programming
languages it will be great if you can
master a variety of programming
languages as your target will not be the
same always on that note in addition to
previously mentioned programming
languages we have an additional list of
languages that are also well recognized
for hacking let's have a look at our
honorary mention
first we have ruby the ruby programming
language has been used for exploitation
for quite some time now
there can be a close comparison drawn
between ruby and python based on its
syntax
however ruby is more web focused
ruby can be used to write either small
or large scripts and can be used
interchangeably with bash scripting
it offers good flexibility while writing
exploits
ruby has been used by several hackers to
exploit corporate systems it is not that
easy to master ruby and that is one
reason why mncs look for professionals
who know ruby
second we have pearl although pearl has
lost its old fame it still holds value
in the hacker community for exploit
writing
there are systems that still run on perl
as it was the go to solution once
it is a great language that can help you
manipulate linux text files and help you
create tools and exploits
perl code bases still do occupy a
considerable portion of corporate tools
third on our list is html
many of you might have wondered why we
didn't mention html yet
yes no programming list is complete
without mentioning html
the hypertext markup language html is a
standard markup language used for
creating web pages
it glows the whole internet together and
it is the language of the web
this shows the importance html has
an understanding of html is vital to
play with web applications
html also finds its use in developing
hybrid mobile and desktop apps
html is a must if you want to master
this field having said that html is not
that tough for language to learn hence
it is advised to master html if you want
to compromise web applications
and finally at 4 we have assembly level
language
it is undoubtedly one of the most
powerful yet hardest programming
languages to learn
it is a complicated low-level
programming language
for hacking primitive systems assembly
is one of the best programming languages
the best part of assembly is that you
can instruct machine hardware or
software using it
assembly language helps a hacker
manipulate systems straight up at the
architecture level
it is also the most suited coding
language to build malware like viruses
and trojans
it is considered to be the best language
for jobs that are time critical
reverse engineers use assembly language
for example if you're interested in
software cracking and if you want to
reverse engineer a piece of software
that has already been compiled assembly
is the go to choice
as complicated as the language sounds
the results it produces are highly
fruitful
so those were the additional programming
languages that can help you become a
skilled and successful hacker we should
keep in mind that a strong understanding
of programming languages helps cyber
security professionals stay on top of
cyber criminals let's talk about hacking
and what exactly hacking is hacking
refers to exploiting weaknesses in a
computer network to obtain unauthorized
access to information a hacker is a
person who tries to hack into computer
systems now here there are some keywords
that we need to understand first and
foremost exploit when you are exploiting
weaknesses weaknesses are technically
called vulnerabilities which are
basically design flaws misconfiguration
errors usage of default usernames and
passwords which have not been modified
so any misconfiguration or anything that
has been left behind by a security
administrator that can be misused which
means exploited by a hacker to gain
unauthorized access so the next term is
unauthorized access something that
you're not allowed to do and when you
say a hacker is a person who tries to
hack it's basically a person with
malicious intent trying to gain access
to a system or a resource that they are
not authorized to access in the first
place how do they do it they find a
vulnerability that is a weakness or a
flaw and then they misuse it to gain
access to that particular network so
here in the diagram you can see that a
sender on the left hand side is trying
to send some data to the receiver on the
right hand side the hacker would try to
gain unauthorized access to the
transmission that is being sent and
would try to capture the data packets
and read the secrets within let's look
at a business case scenario into hacking
now there is an organization everybody
is going around their own business when
they realize that their systems may have
been compromised now they're trying to
look at the customer data to ensure that
that has not been compromised and trying
to assure the customers however they do
realize that some customer data has been
lost and even the company reports have
been modified as well now this is the
scenario where there have been some
security controls in place and those
controls have been identified they
realized that there is an attack that
has happened and based on that attack
they have realized that the data has now
been compromised and the records have
been modified
by the hacker which means that the data
is no longer trustworthy and thus cannot
be used by the business for any legal
transactions so then the hacker gives a
call to the organization or gets
connected to the organization demanding
a ransom for the data to be replaced to
be taken back into the original state
where it was trusted and thus the
organization can utilize it for business
transactions the organization has
probably no backup so they decide that
they want to pay the lump sum to the
hacker to restore that data so that they
can continue on with the business does
money exchanges and the hacker is able
to restore that data and the business
continues that as usual however the
activity here of a hacker trying to
leverage the misconfiguration of the
weaknesses in the organization's
security thus being able to hack them
and make these ransomware demands so the
company then wants to figure out even if
having a security system in place how
was the hacker able to hack their
systems thus one of the employees comes
up with a brilliant idea of identifying
vulnerabilities in the network to
proactively search for any flaws that
have been left behind so that they can
plug those flaws and nobody can misuse
them
thus they figure out that they want to
hire an ethical hacker who would help
them identify the security portion of
the organization identify the weaknesses
vulnerabilities and flaws and help them
remedy those flaws so that in future
scenarios these scenarios will not
happen so before we go into an ethical
hacker let's understand what are the
types of hackers so what are the types
of hackers hacker is a technically
skilled person who is very adept with
computers they have good programming
skills they understand how operating
system works they understand how
networks work they understand how to
identify flaws and vulnerabilities
within all of these aspects and then
they understand and know how to misuse
these flaws to get a outcome which would
be detrimental to the health of the
organization
so there's six type of hackers that have
been identified black hat hackers white
hat hackers grey hat script kiddies
nation's players sponsored hackers and
hacktivists so black hat hackers are
basic basically the malicious hackers
who have malicious intent and have
criminalistic tendencies they want to
harm the organization by hacking into
their infrastructure by destroying their
infrastructure by destroying the data so
that they can gain from it from a
monetary perspective these guys are also
known as crackers the main aspect of
these people are that they have
malicious intent they try to do
unauthorized activities and they try it
for personal gain another important
aspect to remember is that a black hat
hacker will always try to hide their
identity they will spoof their online
digital identity by masking it by
spoofing their ip addresses mac
addresses and try to remain anonymous on
the network a white hat hacker on the
other hand is also an ethical hacker or
a security analyst who is an individual
who will do exactly the same thing that
a black hat hacker would do minus the
malicious intent plus the intent of
helping the organization identifying the
flaws and remedying them so that nobody
else can misuse those vulnerabilities so
they are authorized to act on the
company's behalf they are authorized to
do that activity which would help the
company identify those flaws and thus
help the company mitigate those flaws
improving on their security portion so
these uh these kind of security experts
or ethical hackers would help
organizations defend themselves against
unauthorized attacks grey hat hackers is
a blend of both white hat and black hat
hackers so here they can work
defensively and offensively both they
can accept contracts from organizations
to increase their security posture at
the same time they can also get
themselves involved in malicious
activities towards other organizations
to personally gain or benefit from them
by doing unauthorized activity script
kitties are people uh who are
technically not much aware about what
hacking is uh they rely on existing
tools that have been created by other
hackers they have no technical knowledge
of what they're doing it's just a hit or
miss for them so they just get their
hands on a tool they try to execute
those tools if the hack works it works
otherwise it doesn't so these people are
basically who are noobs or newbies who
are trying to learn hacking or
just uh people who with malice's intent
who just want to have some fun or trying
to impress people around then we have
the nation or the state-sponsored
hackers as the name suggests these
hackers are sponsored by their
government now this may not be a
legitimate job but most of the
governments do have hackers enrolled in
their pay on
on their organizations to spy on their
enemies to spy on various countries and
try to figure out uh the aspirations of
those countries so this is basically a
spying activity where you're technically
trying to get access to other countries
resources and then try to spy on them to
figure out what their activities have
been or what their future plans have
been and then we have the hacktivist
who's an individual who has a political
agenda to promote and they promote it by
doing hacking so these guys what is the
difference between a black hat hacker
and a hacktivist the black hat hacker
may try to hide their identity the
hacktivist will claim responsibility of
what they have done so for them it's a
political agenda political cause and
they will try to hack various
organizations to promote their cause
they would probably do this by defacing
the website and posting the messages
that they want to promote on these
websites so what exactly is ethical
hacking then we have discussed the types
of hackers we have identified a
malicious hacker as a black hat hacker
with the intent of doing harm to an
organization's network for personal gain
we have discussed what the ethical
hacker is so an ethical hacker would be
doing the same activity but in an
authorized manner so they would have
legal contracts that they would be
signing with the organization it would
give them a definite scope of what they
are allowed to do and what they are not
allowed to do and the ethical hackers
would function within those scopes would
try to execute those test scenarios
where they would be able to identify
those flaws or those system
vulnerabilities and then they would be
submitting a report to the management of
what they have found they would also
help the management to mitigate or to
resolve those weaknesses so that nobody
else can misuse them later on they might
use the same techniques and the same
tools that black hat hackers do however
the main difference here is that these
guys are authorized to do that
particular activity they're doing it in
a controlled manner with the intent of
helping the organization and not with
the intent of personal gains so who's an
ethical hacker again an ethical hacker
is a highly intelligent highly educated
person who knows how computers function
how programming languages work how
operating systems work they can
troubleshoot they're technically very
adept at computing they understand the
architecture they understand
how various components in a computer
work they can troubleshoot those
components and they can basically be
very good with programming as well now
when i say programming we don't want the
ethical hacker to be a good developer of
applications we want them to understand
programming in such a way that they can
create scripts they can write their own
short programs like viruses worms
trojans or exploits which should help
them achieve the objective that they
have set out for so uh here you can see
the ethical hacker they're individuals
who perform a security assessment of the
companies with the permission of
concerned authorities so what is the
security assessment a security
assessment is finding out the exact
security posture of the organization by
identifying what security controls are
in place how they've been configured and
if there are any gaps in the
configurations themselves so an
organization will hire a hethical hacker
they they would give the ethical hacker
the information about what information
is or what security controls what
firewalls now what idss ipss introgen
detection or intuition prevention
systems antiviruses are already in place
and then they will ask the ethical
hacker to figure out a way to bypass
these mechanisms and see if they can
still hack the organization what is the
need of an ethical hacker the need of an
ethical hacker is proactive security the
ethical hacker would identify all the
existing flaws in an organization and
try to resolve those laws to help secure
the organization from black hat hackers
so ethical hackers would prevent hackers
from cracking into an organization's
network by securing the organization by
improving on their security on a
periodic basis and they would also try
to identify system vulnerabilities
network vulnerabilities or application
level vulnerabilities that would have
been missed or have already been missed
and then tried to figure out a way of
plugging them or
resolving them so that they cannot be
misused by other hackers they would also
analyze an enhanced organization
security policies now what are policies
policies are basically documents that
have been created by an organization of
rules that all the employees need to
follow to ensure that the security of an
organization is maintained for example a
password policy a password policy would
help users in an organization to adhere
to the standards the organization has
identified for a password complexity for
example a password when a user is
creating them should adhere to standards
where they are using random words they
are they contain the alphabet a through
z uppercase and lowercase 0 through 9 as
numerics and special characters and they
are randomized so that the password
becomes much more stronger to prevent
from brute force attacks so what would
an ethical hacker do at this point in
time they would try to test the strength
of the passwords to see if brute force
attacks or dictionary attacks are
possible and if any of these passwords
can be cracked they will ensure that all
the employees are following the policies
and all the passwords are as secured as
the policies want them to be if there
are any gaps in the policies or the
implementation of the policy it is the
ethical hacker's responsibility to
identify those gaps and warn the
organization about it similarly they
would also try to protect any personal
information any data that is owned by
the organization that is critical for
the functioning of the organization and
they will try to protect it by from
falling into the hackers hands now what
are the skills that are required of an
ethical hacker these are the following
skills so first and foremost they should
have good knowledge with operating
systems such as windows linux unix and
mac now when we say knowledge about
operating systems it's not only about
how to use those operating systems but
how to troubleshoot those operating
systems how these operating systems work
how these operating systems need to be
configured how can they be secured for
example securing an operating system is
not only installing a firewall and an
anti-virus but you need to configure
permissions on an operating system of
what users are allowed to do and what
users are not allowed to do for example
limiting the installation of
applications how are we going to do that
we need to go into the system center the
security center of windows and we need
to configure security parameters over
there of what are acceptable softwares
and what are not same with linux and mac
software operating systems so we need to
know how we can secure these operating
systems similarly all of these would
have desktop versions and server
versions of operating systems as a
ethical hacker we need to know the
desktop and server versions both how to
configure them and how to provide
services within the organization on
these servers so that they can be
consumed in a secure manner by all the
employees at the same time they should
also be knowledgeable of programming
languages or scripting languages such as
php python ruby html for programming if
you will because web servers come into
the picture so again they should not be
great developers where they can create
huge applications but they should be
able to develop scripts understand those
scripts analyze those scripts and figure
out what the output should be of those
scripts to achieve the hacking goals
that they have set out for an ethical
hacker should have a very good
understanding about networking no matter
whether you're in application security
you're in network security or you're in
host-based security since a computer
will always be connected to a network
either a local area network like a lan
or the internet we should know how
networking works we should know the
seven layers of the osi model we should
know which protocols work on those seven
layers we should identify the tcp model
and how osi model can be mapped to the
tcp model we should understand how tcp
and udp work how how each and every
protocol is crafted how they are
supposed to behave for us to analyze and
understand any network based attacks we
should be very good in security measures
so we should know where those
vulnerabilities would lie what are the
latest exploits available in the market
and we should be able to identify them
we should be able to know the techniques
and the tools of how to deal with
security how to analyze security and
then how to implement security to
enhance it as well along with that it is
important that a security analyst or
ethical hacker is aware of the local
security laws and standards why is that
because an organization cannot do any
illegal activity whatever responses that
they have whatever security mechanisms
whatever security controls they will
implement they need to be adhering to
the local law of the land they should be
legal in nature and should not cause
undue harm to any of the employees or
any of the third party clients that they
are dealing with so the ethical hackers
should be aware of what security laws
are before they implement security
controls or even before they start
testing for security controls and all of
these should be backed up by having a
global certification or a globally valid
certification related to networking
related to security ethical hacking the
law of the land anything and everything
maybe even programming uh it's good to
have a certification in php perl python
ruby and so on so forth why because most
of the organizations when they hire
ethical hackers look out for these
certifications especially globally valid
certifications so that they can be sure
or they can be assured that the person
that they are hiring has the required
skill set so let's talk about a few of
the tools that a ethical hacker would
utilize in the testing scenarios to be
honest there are hundreds of tools out
there what you see on the screen are
just a few examples of them
nessus is a vulnerability scanner what
is a vulnerability scanner it is an
automated tool that is designed to
identify vulnerabilities within hosts
within
operating systems within networks so
they come with their ready-made
databases of all the vulnerabilities
that have already been identified at the
scan the network against that database
to find out any possible flaws or any
possible vulnerabilities that currently
exist on the host or the operating
system or on the network similarly there
would be application scanners like uh
acunetix or arachne that would help you
scan applications and identify flaws
within those applications as well now
all of these are automated tools the
essence of ethical hacker is when these
tools churn out the reports the ethical
hacker can understand these reports
analyze them identify the flaws and then
craft their own exploits or use existing
exploits in a particular manner so that
they can get access or they can bypass
the access or security controls
mechanisms that are already in place how
can they do that with the tool called
metasploit you see that big m there on
the right hand side that m logo is for a
tool called metasploit which is a
penetration testing tool what is a
penetration testing tool it is that tool
that will allow an ethical hacker to
craft their exploits or choose their
exploits for the vulnerabilities that
have been identified by nessus since we
are interacting with computers we will
always be interacting using tools right
so the first tool necess identifies the
flaws and the possible list of
vulnerabilities we do a penetration test
using metasploit to validate those flaws
and to verify that those flaws actually
exist and try to figure out the
complexity of those flaws and that's
where metasploit helps us do that
wireshark would be used in the
background while we are doing both the
activities using nessus or metasploit to
keep a track of what packets are being
sent and by received on the network
which will help us analyze those packets
so whenever i run an ss scanner i would
run a wireshark in the background it
will capture the data packets and i can
go through those data packets and
analyze that data package to identify
what nessus is actually trying to do
similarly when i try to attack a machine
using exploit on metasploit i will keep
on wireshark running in the background
to capture the data package that have
been sent and the responses that i have
received from the victim so that i can
also go through those packets and
analyze the responses and analyze the
attack whether it was successful to what
extent was it successful and uh
basically will also give me a validation
of proof of the activity that has
happened nmap is another automated tool
that allows me to scan for open ports
and protocols so why would i use nmap
because pro ports and protocols become
an entry point for a hacker to gain
access to devices for example when we
connect to a web server we connect
through a web browser but we
automatically connect to port 80 using
http and port 443 is using https so if i
am connecting to a web server using
https it is safe to assume that port 443
on the web server is open to accept
those connections similarly there would
be other services that may be left open
on the web server because nobody thought
about configuring it or they
misconfigured the web server and they
left unwanted services running so nmap
will allow me to scan those ports and
services and allow me to understand what
services are being offered on that
server so then i can start analyzing
that server identify those flaws within
those services and then try to attack
them if the application that i'm
analyzing is connected to a database and
i want to do a sql injection attack or
if i if nessus tells me that there is a
sql injection attack that may be
possible on that particular application
i can use an automated tool called sql
map or sql map that would allow me to
automatically craft all the queries that
are required for a sql injection attack
and help me do that attack at the same
time so here i do not have to manually
create my own queries
the sql map tool would automatically
create them for me what i would do is i
would use nessus to identify that
particular flaw if nessus reports that
flaw i would then go use the tool sql
map configure it to attack that
particular web server and when i fire
off the tool it will then automatically
start directing queries sql injection
queries to the database to see if those
databases are vulnerable and if yes what
data can be retrieved from those
databases so all of these tools in a
nutshell would help me hack networks
applications operating systems and host
devices and this is what a ethical
hacker does they use these kind of tool
sets they identify what attacks they
need to do they identify the right tool
for that particular attack and they
write their exploits they create those
attacks and then they start attacking
analyze the response and then give a
report to the management providing them
feedback about how the attack was
created or crafted what was the response
to that attack and whether the attack
was successful or not if successful they
would also give recommendations of what
to do to prevent these attacks from
happening in the future so when we are
doing these attacks or when we want to
launch these attacks what is the process
that we would follow so there are six
steps that we would do as an ethical
hacker if you are just a hacker you
probably wouldn't do the sixth step
which is a reporting step so the first
step that would be done is the
reconnaissance phase which is the
information gathering phase which is
very important from ethical hackers
perspective or a hacker's perspective
because if i want to attack someone or
something as a digital device i need to
know what i'm attacking i need to know
the ip address of the device the mac
address of those devices i need to know
the operating system the build or the
version of that operating systems
applications on top the versions of
those applications so i know what i'm
attacking for example if i if i want to
attack a server i assume it's a windows
based server and i use a particular tool
to attack it but it actually turns out
to be a linux based server my attacks
are going to be unsuccessful so i need
to focus my attack based on what is
there at the other end so in my
information gathering phase i want to
identify all of that information once i
have that information done i'm going to
scan those servers using tools like nmap
that we just talked about and we are
going to try to see the open ports open
services and protocols that are running
on that server that can give me possible
entry points within the network or
within the device or within the
operating system at the same time along
with the scanning with nmap i would run
a vulnerability scanner the nexus
vulnerability scanner we talked about or
acunetix for applications and then i
would try to identify vulnerabilities in
those applications operating systems or
networks once i have identified those
vulnerabilities in the scanning phase i
would then move on to the gaining phase
where i would then craft my exploits or
choose existing exploits and start
attacking the attacking the victim at
this point in time if my attack is
successful i will probably have gained
access
by either tracking passwords or
escalating privileges or exploiting a
vulnerability that i may have found
during the scanning phase once i have
gained my access i want to maintain my
access why because the vulnerability may
not be there for long maybe somebody
updated the operating system and hence
the flaw was no longer exist or existing
or somebody changed the password that we
had i may have cracked does i no longer
have access so what do i do to maintain
my access i installed trojans or
backdoor entries to those systems using
which i can secretly in a covert manner
get access to those devices at my own
will at my own time as long as those
devices are available over the network
so that's where i maintain my access i
have hacked them now i want to maintain
my access so i install a software which
would give me a back door entry to that
device no matter what once i have done
this i want to clear my track so
whatever activity that i've been doing
for example installing a trojan a trojan
is also a software that would create
directory directories and files once
installed on the victim's machine so i
want to hide that if i have access data
stores if i have modified data i want to
hide that activity because if the victim
comes to know that something has
happened they would start they would
start increasing their security
parameters they might start scanning
their devices they may take them offline
thus my hack would no longer be
efficient the reason i'm clearing my
tracks is that the victim doesn't find
out that they have been hacked or they
have been compromised or even if they do
find out that they've been compromised
they cannot trace the compromise back to
me so i would be deleting references of
any of the ip addresses or mac addresses
that i may have used to attack that
particular device and this is where i
will be able to identify where those
logs were created where those traces are
once i
take off those traces the victim would
not be any visor of whether they have
been compromised or who compromised
their system and if i am successful at
all of these stages or what to whatever
extent the success that i've achieved in
any of these stages i would then create
a report based on that and i would
report to the management about the
activities that we have been able to do
and whatever we have been able to
achieve out of those activities for
example we identified 10 different flaws
there were 20 different attacks that we
wanted to do what attack did we do what
was the outcome of that attack what was
the intended or the expected output of
that attack i'll create a report which
would give a detailed analysis of all
the steps that were taken along with
screenshots and evidences of what
activity was conducted what was the
output what was the expected output and
i would submit that report to the
management giving them an idea of what
vulnerabilities and flaws exist in their
environment or their devices that need
to be mitigated so that the security can
be enhanced so these are the six steps
that the ethical hacking process would
take uh just going through this the uh
recognizance is where you're going to
use hacking tools like nmap hp to obtain
information about targets there are
hundreds of tools out there depending on
what information you want then in
scanning again nmap nexpose these kind
of tools to be utilized to identify open
ports protocols and services in gaining
access you're going to exploit the
vulnerability by using the metasploit
tool that we talked about in the
previous slides in the maintaining
access you're going to install back
doors you can use metasploit at the same
time you can craft your own scripts to
create a trojan and install it on the
victims machine once you have achieved
that clearing tracks is where you're
going to clear all evidences of your
activity so that you do not get caught
or the victim doesn't even realize that
they have been hacked and once you have
done all of this we are going to create
reports that are going to be submitted
to the management to help them
understand the current security
evaluation of their organization so now
let's see how we can hack using social
engineering now what is social
engineering social engineering is the
art of manipulating humans into
revealing confidential information which
they otherwise would not have revealed
so this is where your social skill and
your people skills come into the picture
if you are able to communicate
effectively to another person they would
probably give up more information that
they intended to give out let's take a
look at examples right if you see on the
screen fishing activity what is fishing
we receive a lot of frequents on a
regular basis we have always received
those emails where we have won a lottery
of a few million dollars but we have
never realized that we didn't purchase a
lottery to win a lottery in the first
place we have always had those nigerian
frauds where a prince died in some south
african country and u out of seven
billion people on the planet have been
identified where they want to transfer a
few hundred million dollars through your
account and they want to give you 50
percent of that money in return as thank
you so some very basic attacks where you
go onto websites and there's a banner
flashing at you saying congratulations
you're the 1 millionth visitor to this
website click here to claim your price
all of these are social engineering
attacks phishing attacks fake websites
fake communications being sent out to
users to prey on their gullibility most
of humans always have that dream of
striking it rich winning a huge lottery
once and for all and living their life
lavishly ever after but sadly in the
real world that's not that doesn't
happen that often and if you're
receiving those meals it is very
important that you first research the
validity of those those communications
before you even want to act upon them so
why are humans susceptible to social
engineering because humans have emotions
machines do not try pleading with a
machine to give you access to a account
that you have forgotten a password to
the machine wouldn't even know what
you're doing try pleading with a human
sympathy or empathy where you could try
to create a social engineering attack
where you can plead with them saying if
i do not get access to this account
immediately i might lose my job and then
that would put my family into problems
somebody would feel empathy or simply
towards you and help you reset that
password and give you access to that
account it's how good the attack is and
how convincing you are for the success
of this attack to happen so what is a
familiarity exploit attackers interact
with victims to gain information which
will benefit the attackers to crack
credentials as passwords if we want to
reset our passwords what do we have as a
mechanism to resetting passwords we have
some security questions that we set up
those questions are nothing but personal
information that we would know but
through a social engineering attack it
would be easily be able to uh gather the
information that you have set for your
security questions the security
questions can be as simple as the first
school that you attended you probably
have that listed on your linkedin
profile where a person can just go in
there and see your academic
qualifications and identify the school
that you're in right similarly it might
also be a question what was your
mother's maiden name that's a very good
attack and that's i mean if a person can
interact with you let's say they are
trying to take a survey and they
approach you for a feedback on a
particular product that you have been
utilizing and they ask you these
questions you wouldn't think twice
before giving those answers as long as
the request sounds legitimate to us we
are able to justify that request we do
answer those queries so it's upon us to
verify the authenticity of the request
coming in before we answer it phishing
as discussed would be fraudulent emails
which appear to be coming from a trusted
source so email spoofing comes into mind
uh fake websites and so on so forth
exploiting human curiosity curiosity
killed the cat right so there was
there's so many physical attacks where
hackers just keep pen drives lying
around in a parking lot now this is a
open a generic attack whoever falls
victim will fall victim so if i just
throw around a few usbs in the parking
lot obviously with trojans implemented
on them some people who are curious or
who are looking for a couple of freebies
might take up those pen drives plug them
in their computers to see what data is
on the pen drives at the same time once
they plug in those pendrives on their
computers the virus or the trojan would
get infected and cause harm to their
machine then exploiting human greed we
just talked about the
nigerian frauds and the lotteries those
kind of attacks the fake money-making
gimmicks now basically this is where you
prey upon the person's greed kicking in
and they are clicking on those links in
order to get that money that has been
promised to them in that email so one of
the safest mechanism to keep data
private and to keep yourself secure is
using encryption now encryption can
happen through cryptography what is
cryptography cryptography is the art of
scrambling data using a particular
algorithm so that the data becomes
unreadable to the normal user the only
person with the key to unscramble that
data would be able to unscramble it and
make sense out of that data so we're
just making it unreadable or
non-readable by using a particular key
or a particular algorithm and then we're
going to send the key to the end user
the you end user using the same key
would then decrypt that data if anybody
compromises that data while it is being
sent over the network since it is
encrypted they would not be able to read
it so the encryption algorithm would be
something like this now if you see uh
the computer word once made into
unreadable format would
look like eq or xvgt for an end user it
wouldn't make any sense but the person
who has a key to unscramble that would
be able to convert it back to computer
and then understand the meaning of that
word so this is just a substitution
cipher that is being shown on the screen
so what is the alphabet the key is
alphabet plus three so c plus three
alphabets that becomes e o becomes q m
becomes o so the key that is utilized to
scramble the data is the character that
you are at the third character from
there would be the corresponding key so
the encrypted message is also known as a
cipher the decryption is just the other
way around where you know the key now
and you can now figure out what that e
corresponding to by going back three
characters in the alphabet most of the
times a certified ethical hacker must
decrypt a message without knowing the
secret key so let's say a ransomware has
affected your organization or has
affected a device and you want to figure
out uh or you want to decrypt that data
now as an ethical hacker you wouldn't be
for paying a ransom to the hacker would
you so it is now your prerogative of how
you're going to work around and how
you're going to try to crack the
encryption mechanism how to crack the
cipher to decrypt that message and see
what's within it right decryption
without the use of a secret key that is
known as a cryptanalysis cryptanalysis
is the reversing of an algorithm to
figure out what the decryption was uh
without using a key so cryptanalysis can
be done using various formats the first
one is a brute force attack second is a
dictionary attack the third one is a
rainbow table attack a brute force
attack is trying every combination
permutation and combination of the key
to figure out what the key was it is 100
successful but may take a lot of time a
dictionary attack is where you have
created a list of possible encryption
mechanisms a list of possible cracks and
then you try to figure out whether those
cracks work or not rainbow tables are
where you have an encrypted text in hand
and you're trying to figure out the
similarities between between the text
that you have and the encrypted data
that you wanted to decrypt in the first
place so in the brute force attack
you're trying every possible combination
permutation of what the key would be in
dictionary attack you have a word list
that would tantamount to the key and if
you're you're trying to match all the
words listed in the text file or the
word list to see if any of those words
are going to work to decrypt that data
here in the rainbow table the cipher
text is compared with another cipher
text you find out similarities and then
you try to work or reverse engineer your
way accordingly so let's have a quick
demo on cryptography before we begin
this session so to begin with the demo
of cryptography we are on our website
called spammic.com which will help us
scramble the message that we created
into a completely uh format which would
be unrelated to the topic at hand so if
i say i want to encode a message i turn
a short message into spam so what this
does is i want to send across a secret
message you type in the secret message a
short one it will convert that into a
spam mail you send it across so
whoever's reading that spam mail would
never get an idea of the embedded
message within it so if i want to type
in a message here hi this is a secret
message the password is asd at the rate
one two three four and i want to send
this out to people or to one of my
colleagues but i want to send it out in
a secret manner so that others are not
aware of this so when i press on encode
what the algorithm will do is it will
convert this message into a spam mail so
my message hi this is a secret message
the password is at the rate one two
three four or asd at the rate one two
three four gets converted into this now
if you read it dear e-commerce
professional this letter was specially
selected to be sent to you this doesn't
make sense there is nowhere or no
reference to the actual message that
i've already said so if i copy this
entire message and i send it let's say
via email to the recipient now the thing
is that the recipient needs to know that
i've encoded it using spam mimic the
algorithm remain needs to remain the
same so once they know that it is spam
mimic what they can do is now in this
instance what i'm going to do is i'm
going to open up a new browser and i'm
going to go to the same website and at
this point in time i'm going to click on
decode when i click on decode i'm going
to paste the message that i've just
copied there we are and this message is
now being copied into a different
browser and if i decode this you will
see that it will convert it back to the
original message that there was so the
key is there at spam mimic and it is
embedded within the message so whenever
we paste the message in the decode
factor it knows what the key was and it
can decrypt that message and give me the
actual message that was embedded within
it there we are the entire message this
is what we created in the google chrome
browser and in the firefox browser we
decoded similarly if i want to protect
these kind of messages there is an aspen
encrypt.com website where let's say we
use text encryption and i want to
encrypt the same message this
is a
secret message the password is asd at
the rate one two three four and then i
give it a password to protect this
message let's say the word password and
i use the cipher to scramble this by
using let's say aes which is the
strongest cipher right now and i say
encrypt so this is what the encryption
would look like and basically if i don't
have the password over here if i decrypt
it you would see that the error has
occurred if i type in the password over
here and then decrypt it it will be able
to convert that back into the
unscrambled text and it will give me
what the original message was this is a
secret message the password is asd at
the rate one two three four so if i want
to keep my data secure from hackers i
want to scramble it in such a way that
they would not be able to crack it or it
would be very difficult for them to
crack it and this is one of the first
mechanisms that would be recommended by
any ethical hacker to keep the data
secure now let's talk about downloading
and installing kali linux along with
that we'll also be looking at the basic
commands that are required for kali
linux alright so i've opened my browser
and we want to go to the kali website so
we want to go to kali.org
you can directly type in kali dot org
and go to the website i can just do a
google search and say kali download and
it will give you the same website but it
will directly take you to the downloads
pages so either here and or you can go
to the home page uh cookies are being
installed on your machine so uh see
which cookies you want to allow i'm only
going to use the necessary cookies to
support the site and you can see that
this gives you the latest kali linux
news and tutorials gives you the latest
release what is in that release and
gives you a lot of documentation which
will help you understand what tools have
been developed and what functionality
has been given in the latest version if
you want to download you can directly go
here and you can download kali linux now
kali linux is a 2.6 gigabyte download so
it's going to take time the latest
version being 2019.4
and we click over here i'm using a
download manager to manage all these
huge downloads and you can see it's
pointed to the operating systems folder
and it is going to be a 2.57 gb download
so you click on download and in the
background uh you can see this is going
to be downloaded and you're going to
minimize this and
it will take a few minutes for that to
download but this is an iso image so we
need to install it on a virtual machine
so what we need is we need to use a
hypervisor which will allow us to create
virtual machines so we can either use
vmware workstation which you can
download from here however
this is paid version so you can see it
is around 250 or something for this
software but it is a very good software
to have so if you click on download now
it is going to start the download it's a
30-day trial period if you want to use
it after 30 days you'll need to enter
the key which you'll get after
purchasing the software if you do not
want to utilize this the free version
that you have you can either download
vmware player but there are some
limitations for vmware player that you
might want to look at does you want to
compare these products before you want
to purchase them right otherwise you can
download oracle virtualbox which is a
free hypervisor it's not as robust as
vmware workstation but it does the trick
right so the the free version 6.1 is
free and you can then create your own
virtual machines over there and install
operating systems on them what i do have
i already have a vmware workstation
installed so i'm just going to open that
up and that's my vmware workstation as
you can see i already have a lot of
virtual machines created over here what
we are going to do is we are going to
configure a virtual machine for the kali
linux operating system that we are
downloading which should be somewhere
here let's see it's at 43 percent so
halfway there till then let's create the
virtual machine so i click click on file
create a new virtual machine i'm going
to customize the machine so click on
next this little default we don't want
to change that and then we want to
install the operating system later we
don't want to point it out right now so
i'll just click on i will install the
operating system later click on next we
want to install linux now in the drop
down you would not see kali linux over
here however you can choose ubuntu
64-bit that's what i'm going to choose
there it is next
what is the name that we want i want to
give it kali linux without the typo and
i want to store it in one of the folders
that i've created by default it stores
on the c drive which is not a good place
to store uh you don't want to run out of
space on your c drive so i'm going to
click on this pc and
this is my
data and in here i'll have a folder
called virtualbox or virtual machines
there it is within which you can see the
other softwares that i already created
i'm going to create a new folder and
call it kali 2019 l l for it is latest
for me because you can see already have
a kali linux so i'm just going to
identify this folder with the l at the
end going to select it and click on ok
you can see the path being changed over
here click on next it's going to ask you
how many processors now depending on the
processor that you have you can see i've
got a 8 core i7 so if i give it 16 cores
or 16 processors that's not going to
work i cannot go beyond what the
physicality already is so for this
machine one processor with one core is
more than enough if you're going to load
use a lot of tools at the same time you
might just want to give it two cores so
given it two cores it will ask us for
ram to be provided for this virtual
machine by default 2048 megabytes that's
2gb of ram is more than enough if you
require more we can change this later on
so click on next we want to use nat for
now leave this default next whatever is
recommended keep it the way it is we do
not want to change it next create a new
virtual hard disk for this machine and
it is going to ask us the size 20 gb is
more than fine store it as a single file
you don't want to use multiple file
options click on next and then click on
browse wherever you want to store the
vmdk file or the virtual hard disk file
and we go back again to the same folder
that we had created virtual machines and
we look at the kali linux kali 2019 l
and we want to store the vmdk file over
there once we save it we want to click
on next and then we want to click on
finish so this is the virtual machine
that has been created right here right
now this is the basic configuration now
where are we at with the operating
system and you can see the operating
system has been downloaded and it is
stored in this particular folder so we
go to e drive so we are looking for the
sub the operating system that we have
downloaded we downloaded in the
operating systems folder and if we go in
here you can see the current one the
kali linux 2019.4 iso right here so what
we do we go back to the kali linux
machine that we have created edit
virtual machine settings and we point
this virtual machine using the cd dvd
and then we point the iso the one that
we downloaded over here so we go back to
e drive we go back to os and we click on
kali linux 2019 click on open so now
when this boots up it will boot up with
this iso and then it will allow us to
install the operating system so click on
ok then we click on power on this
virtual machine it will start powering
on it will boot to the iso and it will
start giving us the booting option so
i'm just going to
enter the full screen mode over here for
this to be better visible and we don't
want the live mode what we want is we
want to use the graphical install and
then we highlight that we press enter
and you can see the setup starting up
we'll wait for the gui to pop up there
it is which language do we want for now
we want english click on continue where
are we located click on continue and the
configure your keyboard we want the us
keyboard american english continue it is
going to detect the hardware so as you
can see on the screen it's attempting a
auto configuration for most of these uh
settings the network with dhcp it has
identified the network cards uh hardware
like uh the processor that has been
provided it is asking for a host name
we're going to leave it at default we're
going to click on continue domain name
i'm not joining this into a domain as
yet there's going to be a standalone
machine so i can leave this blank click
on continue now it is going to configure
the network it is asking for a password
at this point in time the root password
type in any password that you want
ensure that you remember the password
now by default the username for the
account is the name is the word root we
are just creating the password for the
root account and then we want to click
on continue setting up the clock looking
at the hard disks now here it asks us do
you want to use the entire disk the 20
gb virtual hard disk that we had
provided or do we want to give it a
manual configuration or a guided one
where we want encryption and a logical
volume management coming into the
picture we're just going to use the
first option guided you use entire disk
don't worry it's only going to use the
virtual disk that we had created click
on continue it will give us that it's a
21.5 gb vmware virtual disk that we had
and click on continue all files in one
partition that's what we want
recommended for new users whatever it is
we don't want to change these folders
continue and this is what we have
configured once we click on continue it
is going to say you are you sure you
want to make these changes click on yes
click on continue and it will start
installing kali linux on your device now
this is going to take a few minutes for
the installation to work all right so
that's the installation that's completed
now it's asking us to configure a
package manager a network mirror can be
used to supplement the software that is
included on the installation media this
may also make new versions of software
available you want to use a network
mirror we can click no for now and then
click on continue now this is going to
install the grub bootloader this might
take a few minutes as well install the
group grub loader to the master boot
record yes click on continue click the
hard disk that you have just utilized
this is the one click on continue it
will install the grub book loader
running through the last phases of the
installation and now it says the
installation is complete we want to
click on continue finishing the
installation and then it will do a
reboot all right and you can see this is
starting up so we are going to use you
just wait out the boot and now it
started the booting sequence just going
to maximize the screen and you can see
it's asking me for the password this is
the one that we created now that's the
that's not the password that's the
username that's the root and the
password that we had created at that
point in time and then click on log in
and this is your screen
now what we need to do here is we need
to install vmware tools which will help
us manage the screen and help the
virtual machine to be a little bit
better integrated on the system so
that's
not mounted yet so we're just waiting
for it to mount there it is and what we
want to do here is open vmware tools
upgrader all right so what we want is we
want to extract or we want to use this
open x archiver and once we do that
we'll see the vmware install dot pl
double click on that all right we've got
the vmware tools here what i've done is
we have extract2 and i've extracted that
on the desktop right so what we just did
was click on the desktop over here open
and this is what it will do and click on
extract now that is happening because
i've already extracted this open this up
we want to run this vmware install dot
pl so what do we do we open up the
terminal window which is the command
line interface over here and now this is
where some of the commands come into the
picture so for example pwd will show us
the present working directory ls will
show us the list of the folders that are
there so the folder that we have is on
our desktop so we'll just change
directory to desktop press enter do an
ls that will show us the list and you
can see vmware tools distribute that's
the folder that we have right here right
so we want to go into that folder see
the vmware at this point you can just
click on tab and it will populate
everything over there press enter do an
ls and we want the vm where hyphen
install dot pl to be executed all right
so we tried executing that command we
had an error over there so what we need
to do is we need to execute this command
so dot slash vmware
hyphen install.pl and we'll start
creating now it will ask you for your
input installing vmware tools in which
directory do you want to install the
binary files uh by default it is going
to use slash usr slash bin if i just
press
enter it is going to use the default as
you can see the input over here what
directory do you want the init
directories i'm just going to press keep
on pressing enter for the defaults to
come in this part does not exist it is
going to create it default yes defaults
everywhere and then it tries to start
initializing it to maximize the screen
and this is where it is installing and
you can see by just installing that it
automatically adjusted the screen and
now we got a full screen of kali linux
right here right and that is what vmware
tools does for us once we have installed
the operating system and now you can see
the entire screen on here you will see
the tool sets that are given here now
why are we using kali linux in the first
place because this comes in uh with a
bundle of thousands of softwares that
are ready to be utilized for ethical
hacking right and they have been
categorized over here for information
gathering vulnerability analysis web
application analysis and so on so forth
so you can see from forensics onwards
reporting tools and as you scroll down
you can see your development tools
graphics coming in internet and the
system configuration coming into the
picture these are your settings for your
operating system so these are basically
your tools we are right now the
favorites if i click on information
gathering you will see that other tools
for information gathering start
appearing over here for vulnerability
analysis we have got sparta nmap fuzzing
tools web application analysis we have
got comics skip fish sql map database
assessments password attacks and so on
so forth so if you just go in the
favorites this was the terminal emulator
that we utilized is the command line
that we saw we used the cd command we
use the pwd command we did the ls
command as well to give us the list of
the directory that we are in similarly
there would be commands like cat so
let's go to cd downloads let's see what
the uh what's there i can see this case
sensitive so if i type in a capital d
and then do a tab ls there's nothing
over here on download so cd dot dot will
take us back one directory now you can
see we are back from downloads to root
if i want to go to desktop this is how i
go to desktop do a ls you can see the
vmware tools uh folder over there cd
vmware tools and we go into that folder
ls which will give us the list of all
those files now you can see install is a
file that we had edited back then so if
i do a cat install you will see the cat
basically is the command that will help
us look at the contents of the file all
right without opening up the file
without editing the file so you can see
just uh if i scroll up this is where we
give the cat command it then
printed the contents of the file over
here and then it exited and gave me back
to command line right here right now if
i want to copy this cp root desktop
vmware install and if you want to copy
it to root downloads and press enter now
what we are going to do is we are going
to see if this file the install file
that we just edited over here has been
copied to the downloads folder so we do
us we are currently in the vmware on the
desktop vmware tools district folder
video cd dot dot that takes us down one
directory so we are still in the desktop
do a cd dot dot now you can see we are
back in the root and now we are going to
do a cd downloads run ls and you can see
the copied file right here so if i do a
cat install you can see the same content
of that file coming in so these are some
of the commands that we would need to
learn as we go ahead the remove command
is
let's say we've got install we do a man
rm man is the manual page command that
uh gives us the
pages with the description of how that
particular command is to be utilized so
rm is remove files or directories
synopsis is the description the options
hyphen f4 hyphen i for prompt hyphen
capitalize prompt once before removing
more than three files and so on so forth
if you want to exit this you can press q
to exit and you come back to this page
so if i say rm install ls you will see
that the install file has now been
deleted so in windows we use the del del
command in linux it is the rm command so
this is what we wanted to look at the
demo for kali linux how to download it
how to install it and some of the basic
commands that we can utilize all right
let's begin with the fishing uh tutorial
we have the kali linux operating system
booted up over here uh what we are going
to do is we are going to open up a tool
called set social engineering toolkit
which you would find in this option and
that's the tools that we want it's a
command line tool a menu driven tool we
are going to host a fake facebook page
and we can see how we can harvest
credentials by this kind of an attack so
these are some disclaimers you might
want to go through that do you want to
agree to the terms of service
yes
press enter and that's your social
engineering toolkit and we are talking
about a phishing attack which can comes
under the social engineering attack so
it like i said it's a menu driven tool
so we just have to look at these options
and then just type in the number of the
option that we want so we want to do a
social engineering attack so i type in
one press enter in that it is asking me
whether i want a spear phishing attack a
website attack vector we are going to
choose a second option so i type in two
press enter and then it asks me uh what
i want to do i want to take the third
option here credential harvester attack
methodology and we want to do the third
attack now it is asking whether we want
to use the in-house website templates
that it already has or do we want to
clone a site or do we have a customized
site that we have prepared that we want
to migrate into this tool we are going
to do the site cloning option so we're
going to type in two press enter and
then it is going to ask me the ip
address where it wants to capture and
store the credentials by default this is
the ip address that i'm using so if i
leave it blank it will take my default
ip address so i'm just going to press
enter and now it is asking me the url to
clone so i type in https
www.facebook.com what it is going to do
it is going to connect online and it is
now just it has cloned the website uh
facebook login.php the best way to use
this attack is that you if you use the
if the username and password form are in
the same field or the same page
regardless this captures all posts on a
website so you may need to copy www star
into html depending on where your
directory structure is press return if
you understand what we are seeing here
so press enter the social engineering
toolkit credential harvest attack is
running on port 80 information will be
displayed to you as it arrives so the
site was 71.134
right the default ip address and this is
where the website is being hosted let's
check that out so let me open up a
browser on my host machine and let me
point it to the kali linux machine that
we have just created 192.168.71.134
and you should see a login to facebook
coming up right here looks genuine it is
genuine because we just went online and
downloaded this let's just have a recap
let's have a explanation of what we are
trying to do i am trying to host fake
facebook page on my server which has an
embedded script in it which is going to
do credential harvesting so the attack
here is let's say if i'm now hosted this
i can craft a fake email send it across
to a victim saying uh your facebook
account has seen some unforeseen
activity create a hyperlink using html
coding within that click here to access
your account and verify uh that the
account is secured and when they click
on that link they will be redirected to
my fake page which is here you can see
the ip addresses my virtual machine's ip
address but i'm seeing a facebook login
page and i'm going to type in someone at
somewhere.com and the password i'm just
going to type in the regular ones that i
use and if you see it when we typed in
uh the username and password the page
just refreshed and gave us the login
page again but now if you look at the
url i'm actually on facebook's login
page which is exactly the same that i
was hosting so a layman wouldn't
probably figure out they've been hacked
by now they just would figure out okay
they probably typed in the incorrect
password and the page refresh or
something like that and they're just
going to log in and they're actually
going to access the facebook page thus
they might not even realize that
something went wrong but if i go back to
my virtual machine you can see that it
has captured some data and it is
reporting over here of what has happened
so if i just scroll up let's see what
happened here and if you have been able
to capture anything so we gotta hit
printing the output this does the http
1.1 200 okay response coming in password
field phone
and
we just looking there it is email
someone at somewhere.com and
uh password that i typed in asd1234
so it has captured the username and the
password right here uh once you're done
i mean this is the way attackers work
now this is a very basic attack again uh
in the actual trainings you would then
look at how you would host this on a
real website make it a global attack
right now it's a virtual machine with a
class cip address so here the thought
process is where can we get a free
hosting where we can host this kind of
sites maybe i'll have to purchase a
domain which looks like similar to
facebook or the victim that i'm trying
to attack so this is just a poc so we
just wanted to find out if we can how
fishing is done and this is exactly how
it is done right so pressing ctrl c
would exit this tool and takes you back
to the actual menu press 99 99 to exit
and
there it is close the two window and
that's
the phishing practical after phishing
let's talk about sql injection sql
injection stands for
structured query language injection
which is a database attack though it
resides within the application so it's
the application vulnerability that we
are trying to look at to try to bypass
authentication as the name suggests a
sequel injection vulnerability allows an
attacker to inject malicious input into
a sql statement what is a sql statement
a query that is used by an application
and is fired off to the database
database executes that query gets that
information that is required and sends
it back to the user if the user is
authenticated so we're going to look at
the sql injection attack demo here and
what we are going to do is we are going
to go back to our vmware workstation and
i have got a tool over here called ovast
broken web application which is a
utility that has been created for people
like us to test our skills to learn on
how we can develop our skills further so
this has a lot of vulnerable
applications built within it we're just
going to try to access it and we are
going to see if we can create a sql
injection attack just waiting for it to
boot up once it boots up it will give us
an ip address there we are so we need to
connect to 71.132
so i can just use the same browser i was
using close up facebook and now go to
192 168
71.132 and this is the ovas broken web
application project uh what we're going
to do is we're going to go to utility
and this is a application that has a lot
of information within it you can see it
gives you links about what you should do
help me video tutorials listing of
vulnerabilities that they have and so on
so forth so you can see we are not
logged in right now i'm just going to do
this as a demo so what we're going to do
is we're going to look at this and
bypass authentication so we are taken to
the login page where you need a username
and password to log in i'm going to type
in test as the username and test as the
password click on login and you can see
that account does not exist so the
authentication mechanism works now what
we want to do is we want to create a
query now what does a query look like
when i type in a username and a password
if i just type in a single quote here it
is going to create an error and this is
what a sql query looks like select
username from accounts where username is
a single quote and then the exception
error happened so it it's not showing
the rest of the query to us now what i'm
going to do is i'm just going to craft a
query here uh single quote and give it a
condition or one equals one space hyphen
iphone space what happens hyphen hyphen
space is comments out anything after
that so the password field is being
commented out at this point in time and
i'm just giving it a condition where the
condition is true one does equal one and
if this condition is true it is going to
allow me to log in so you can see right
now we are not logged in this bypasses
the authentication mechanism and you can
see user authenticated and we are now
logged in as admin so uh in the training
what we need to understand uh as a whole
is how sql works what are the queries
that are structured with how you can
what are the testing operators now the
single quote that we used that was an
operator in the sql syntax what these
operators are how they function and then
how you can leverage these attacks there
are different tools that are given to
you in kali as well that you can utilize
so in kali linux you can just open up a
command prompt and there's a tool called
sql map you need to give it a particular
site so sql map hyphen u for the url and
whatever the url is now url here and
then once you're here you just press the
enter key this tool will craft all the
queries in the background for you you
don't even have to no sql query or sql
languages this is a very easy tool to
utilize sadly i cannot demo this on a
live website because that would be
illegal but you can see how you can
operate this yourself that's what sql
injections are all about moving on we
now talk about uh vpn's virtual private
networks and a virtual private network
is basically a secure network that
allows me to anonymize myself over the
internet so what i'm doing is i'm
connecting from here to a server that
encrypts my channel encrypts my
connection and does allows me to keep my
data secure now the basic essence of a
vpn or a virtual private network is to
allow me this encryption mechanism where
i can encrypt and safeguard my data the
added advantage that nowadays a vpn
gives is that you can allow us to spoof
our ip address or obfuscate our ip
address so we can actually become
anonymous on the internet it can allow
us to use multiple ip addresses and does
secure ourselves on the internet for
example i use vpn called cyberghost and
what this allows me to do is it allows
me so many servers over here and if you
look at the entire list all the servers
then there are no spy servers which and
guarantee me that they are not going to
keep and store any logs and thus they
are not going to record any of the
activity that i'm doing right since they
are located out of romania this becomes
a little bit more safer for me because
the government and the laws over there
are a little bit more relaxed than other
countries uh they give me uh different
links for torrenting for streaming for
connection features so uh there are a
lot of vpns out there so for example
let's go to the website cyberghost.com
so we can see there's a sale going on 76
percent sale or you can go on to express
vpn which is also a very good vpn then
there is not vpn it depends on what you
want and how you want to utilize it so
just purchasing a vpn or getting a free
free vpn is not enough it depends on
which country the vpn originates from
and which server you're connected to for
example most of the countries have a
pact where they share information
amongst themselves even if you're
connected to a vpn that means that these
companies that provide these services
have to generate and store logs and
these logs have to be reported to the
government if they ask for it now if
there's a list of 14 countries that
actually uh focuses on this practice so
you have to find out vpn that and a
server that is not a part of those 14
countries and ensure that those logs are
not going to be reported to the
government and these are three vpns
basically are something that which are
good and i personally use cyberghost i
have used the others i just keep on
rotating them just to get an idea of
which one is better so
these are vpns that can allow you to
anonymize yourself on the internet
moving on uh these are the ones that we
talked about there are other safer vpn
hide my ass expressvpn and so on so
forth from our terminologies let's now
talk about vps vps is basically virtual
private server where you can rent a
service or server as a service a virtual
machine as a server so basically on a
cloud using infrastructure as a service
you can rent a server and utilize it for
whatever activity you want so let's go
to uh these sites register.com go to id
network solutions or we can talk about
other cloud solutions as well so here
you can get register your domain names
so in the previous exercise for let's
say when we talked about the phishing
exercise uh what we want is we can go on
to register.com or we can go on to
godaddy.com and we can purchase a
particular domain for example something
like this instead of the o's i'm typing
in a couple of zeros for the facebook
and see let's see if anything of that is
available now something dot photo is
available or
facetips.com is available uh there are
other options that are making over here
that they're giving us over here and
once we purchase this we can then have
our own hosting uh with our web hosting
as a service and uh you can have a linux
based uh hosting or a based hosting
depending on what you want and that's
where your shared hosting comes with the
picture if you just want uh if you want
to look at a virtual server and you want
to render server over there itself you
can move on to rackspace.com
and here in your services
you can have physical server or a
virtual server in a public cloud your
other cloud providers for example would
be amazon aws and on aws you can
basically look at ec2 elastic compute
cloud which is basically virtual servers
in the cloud and over here you can rent
out a server with whatever capacity you
require you'll obviously have to pay
rent for what those servers are going to
cost but once you have those servers you
can then launch any services on top of
it looking at other services that we
have we talked about tor tor is a onion
routing software that allows users to
browse the web anonymously so we can
just go online and we can try to spoof
our identity and i'm going to show you
how so i've got a vmware workstation
right here the one so we're just going
to pull that up and we're going to power
on a windows 7 machine where we're going
to look at the onion routing so windows
machine has booted up we're just going
to log in and this is my windows 7
machine now i've got a chrome browser
right here and we're going to go to a
website called cmyip.com which is going
to give the ip address that i'm
currently using so right now i'm not on
connected to any vpn or anything and you
can see that's my ip address that i'm
utilizing now if i want to anonymize
myself what i'm going to do is i am
going to use star and that's the tower
browser that's set up right there if i
click on it it's going to open up the
software and it's going to create a new
network and it's going to connect to the
tor network and allow me to anonymize
myself right so that's the third browser
opening up and uh giving me a new
browser over here so i've got one which
is the old one which is uh my current ip
address if i just refresh that you'll
see that i'm still on the same ip
address as far as this browser is
concerned there's the refresh and it's
still showing me the same ip address
where if i go on to thor right now and
if i go to see my ip.com you will see
that it is going to give me and you can
see the amount of time it is taking to
reach that site that's because i am
using a vpn and there's a lot of
encryption running off and you can see
now i'm certainly connected via hong
kong and even to reach this site what
tor does is it gives me a proxy chain a
proxy chain is where it creates multiple
hops to hide my identity and before i
reach see my ip.com i am using three
different ip addresses over here one in
france one in germany and one in hong
kong so if i do something over here to
trace back my steps to my actual ip
address the law enforcement agencies or
anyone who is going to search
like a forensic investigator would have
to go through these ip addresses before
they come back to me now it's not
impossible but the effort and time
that's going to be taken to come across
three different countries is going to be
phenomenal so it may just defeat the
purpose of having so much resources
spent to identify who did what so that's
what tot does for us all right moving on
from tor we are going to look at key
loggers keyloggers are basically
softwares that run in the background and
record all the keystrokes of the user so
if i've got a keylogger installed right
now whatever i type will be stored in a
text file for the hacker so that they
can look at it later on and just to give
you an example of that we go back to my
vmware workstation and we open up
another windows 7 machine i'm going to
power this on and i'm going to close
this one till then so this virtual
machine has booted up we are going to
use user one login as user one just
close all these softwares which are not
required and once this machine is booted
up what we're going to do is i'm just
going to open up a random websites and
see what we're doing basically there's a
key logger that's there in the startup
that's
going to record our keystrokes and we
just want to see what it actually does
now firefox is getting updated so let's
hold on now this is the latest version
of firefox right and we're just going to
go to let's say facebook.com
wait for the website to open up all
right let's try opening it up again and
that's facebook.com and we're just going
to type in some random username and
password somewhere someone at
somewhere.com and the password being
again asd at the rate one two three four
five six seven eight nine zero log in
obviously that login is not going to
work user probably doesn't exist or if
it does the password probably is correct
incorrect and uh so we're going to close
this we're going to let's say open up
another browser window go to another
site uh readdiff.com
and then go to red if mail try the same
thing over here someone at somewhere.com
password is right one two three four
five six seven whatever it is don't say
we can see the combination is incorrect
now there's a keylogger running in the
background and what we want is we now
want to open up the keylogger now it is
visible here because i've kept it
visible you can hide it in the start
menu and there's a shortcut key for you
to pull it up later on so this
completely becomes invisible and
what it can do is it basically creates a
record of whatever you have been doing
so far so you can see these things
populating on the 25th of december so if
i look at the visited website you can
see i opened up mozilla firefox the
first where it uh there was a problem
loading the page then we opened up
facebook then we opened up
rediffmail.com and so on so fortune this
it just gives me the list of visited
websites whereas if i look at keystrokes
and clipboard you will see whatever we
have typed in so we first typed in
facebook.com then again uh the second
time i try try to type in then i hit
backspace then i type in facebook.com
and then you can see i typed in someone
at somewhere.com and then tab asd at the
rate one two three four five six seven
eight nine zero we closed up the browser
we opened up a new one and we went on to
redifemail.com and then you can see
me typing this one then going back one
space then the rest of what i typed and
then the password coming in so that's
what a keylogger does if you look at the
taskbar it's not going to show you a
keylogger running in the background it's
in processors you're not going to see
anything at all but it's going to mask
itself as a service so if you look into
the properties you can see that icon
coming in over here which matches this
one and so you can see that this is
masking itself as a service dot exe if
this gets hidden as well it would be
very difficult for a user to even
identify this all right so that's what a
key logger is moving on let's see what
else we want to talk about so we've
talked about tor we have talked about
key loggers and now we want to talk
about firewalls now for keyloggers to be
prevented we need antiviruses right so
we need a good antivirus program that's
going to be installed updated and run on
a regular basis to protect ourselves
from malwares but what about network
connections and you need a firewall in a
system to prevent or to detect what kind
of connections are going on in the first
place now we cannot rely on software's
100 percent so even if a firewall is not
configured properly that's that's going
to be a problem so what we need to do is
we have to have a firewall configure it
correctly and then allow and disallow
certain
activity from of uh happening and what
we're going to do is i've got such a
system on my machine here i use a
software called glass wire what it does
is it is a network analyzer so it allows
me to analyze whatever is going on you
can see all the apps that i'm utilizing
and how much upload and download they
have been doing all the traffic so you
can see the protocols that i'm utilizing
so i come to know what's going on in the
background and this gives me the entire
graph of how much i have been doing for
the past 24 hours past three hours past
five minutes and so on so forth right so
this is what the activities and these
are the alerts that it has been
generating i can click on those alert
and it will start telling me what it was
all about if the graph doesn't work for
me it gives me usage as well so how much
i have utilized since i've installed
this software right and what
applications have been utilized which
host i've been connected to and the
traffic type that was utilized and then
the things on my network so these are
the devices that i have currently on my
network that has been that have been
identified and then comes the firewall
so on the firewall the firewall is
clicked on you see all those services
that have been identified and you can
just click on a particular service to
lock that service so this becomes a
discovery tool identifies whatever
networking is going on gives me all that
information and then i can look at and i
can just click on any of these services
that i find it as malicious and block
them i can create different profiles for
different applications as i'm as and
when i want them and these are the
alerts so you can see that this was the
first time a network connection was
looked at from vmware and what this
allows me to do is whenever i execute a
file it can upload it to virustotal.com
and scan it as a third-party antivirus
to ensure that there is nothing
malicious on it so i already have an
antivirus over here but if this ever
gets compromised i still can rely on a
third-party service where in real time
as an and when i execute my applications
they would be verified and i would be
assured that nothing is wrong with my
system and this software that i'm
utilizing glasswire basic is free and
then there are paid versions as well
it's just glasswire.com is where you're
going to find this moving on rootkit
rootkits are also malicious softwares
that you allow and unauthorized user to
have access to a computer to restrict
areas of its software now a rootkit in
is a census which a software a malicious
software that infects a machine and
prevents a from some functionality from
it like hiding data or preventing users
from running anti-viruses and it's
basically a malicious software that is
used to hide information from the
victims so that they would not realize
that they have actually been compromised
it's going to be a difficult showing of
a root kit so i cannot show that demo to
you so we're just going to move on and
we're going to talk about ethical
hacking techniques now now when we say
ethical hacking techniques we want to
look at what kind of audits are
available when we want to do ethical
hacking so there's a black box audit a
white box audit and a gray box audit so
if i'm invited in an organization to
conduct a test to conduct a audit to
conduct a vulnerability assessment or a
penetration test to identify
vulnerabilities and then try to plug
them out they are going to give me three
different variations in a black box
audit they are not going to tell me
about the infrastructure they are not
going to give me any information and
they want me to start from the basics of
gathering information identifying the
systems and based on the information
that i gather whether i'm able to
develop any hacks and compromise their
infrastructure so it will be a
simulation of a hacker who's sitting
outside the organization and trying to
find a way in whereas a white box
auditors were full infrastructure
knowledge is given anything and
everything that is required for an audit
is given and this is a simulation of an
insider attack a person sitting inside
the organization misusing their
permissions and then trying to
compromise trying to get access to data
that they do not have access to so the
simulation is from a malicious insider a
gray box is where some partial knowledge
is available and from that partial
knowledge you're going to try to build
up more information and then you're
going to try to get access to those
resources what are the tools that we
utilize so we have already had a couple
of demos on keyloggers sql injections
equal map and so on so forth metasploit
is a very much used tool for penetration
testing and uh having knowledge on
metasploit is very much necessary as far
as ethical hacking is concerned nmap
this is a tool used for network
discovery necessary scanner wireshark is
a packet capturer that allows you to
capture packets and analyze whatever is
going on sql map is something that we
have seen a sequel injection attack tool
which uh generates its own queries and
john the ripper is a password cracking
tool uh bactrack used to be an operating
system that was utilized for penetration
testing however backtrack has now been
replaced by something called kali linux
and that's the operating system that we
have utilized in all our demos where we
tried to look at sql map and those
injection attacks that we did so what
are the areas of ethical hacking we have
just talked about all these areas as
well network services we looked at the
glasswire application that showed us how
my machine is consuming networks which
protocols are being consumed how the
connections are being
created if somebody's able to install a
trojan on my machine it is going to try
to create a new connection on the
network with the hacker to allow that
hacker a backdoor access now if i have
that glass wire or a similar firewall
implemented it is this wire wall that is
going to detect it and prevent that
connection from happening so if i
install a software that is certainly
suspicious or that installs something
else in the background that i may not be
aware of that tool is going to identify
all the connections that are being made
and it is going to highlight that
connection i need to go through all of
those connections and identify whether
they are legit or not and if i find some
suspicious or doubtful i'm going to
block that connection and then i'm going
to investigate what's going on and
that's where ethical hacking comes into
the picture you want to find out if your
firewall that you have implemented is
going to work correctly or not if the
configuration of the firewall is done
properly or if the firewall is
misconfigured is it leaking out
information right at the same time
you're looking at web applications we
looked at the ovas broken web
application where we did some sql
injection attacks right so that was a
weakness or a vulnerability in that
application which would allow us to
bypass authentication and get access
to resources that we were not authorized
for and then client-side attack should
be where
you install keylogger at the end of the
at the client system and then you try to
capture whatever data the user is typing
in like usernames and passwords on the
facebook and the rediff mail.com website
that we saw and then try to misuse that
information to get access to those
resources then wi-fi networks right
wi-fi is something that we use on a
regular basis we got our smart devices
nowadays smartphones tablets phablets
that we can connect to wi-fi and start
using all our services our banking
applications and our smartphones and
thus we want to ensure that wireless
connectivity is simple and is secured so
you want to use encryption mechanisms
you want to use tools on your
smartphones antiviruses firewalls on
your smartphones to ensure that whatever
you're utilizing is going to remain
secure and then social engineering we've
looked at the phishing website on
facebook.com we've seen how easy it is
to clone websites and uh host them on
apache server so if you look at it
from ethical hacker's perspective the
job of ethical hacker is to simulate
these kind of attacks that the hacker
may conduct and
first of all you're basically going to
find out areas where these attacks can
happen think of it from a hacker's
perspective try to simulate those
attacks and see if those attacks are
going to be effective can those attacks
be prevented and can your current
security controls that you have put in
place identify detect and prevent these
attacks from happening in the first
place and that is what ethical hacking
is all about let's look at the
metasploit attack metasploit is a
framework of penetration testing that
makes hacking very simple you just need
to know how to utilize the tool you need
to identify the vulnerability associated
with a particular exploit and then run
the exploit on metasploit we'll be
demoing this during the practical so
there are active exploits and passive
exploits inactive exploits exploits a
specific computer runs until execution
and then exits uses brute force and
exits when an error occurs in a passive
exploit these exploits wait for incoming
requests and exploit them as soon as
they connect they can also be used in
conjunction with emails and web browsers
so in passive exploits we create a
payload we like a reverse connection
payload we send it to the victim once
the victim installs that software the
machine will then initiate a connection
to us our machine will be in a listen
mode and then we will once the software
is executed there and we would then try
to connect and exploit that particular
vulnerability this is the practical that
we'll be doing on metasploit so let's
move on with the demos and then we'll
see what we can discuss amongst them all
right let's have a look at some of the
demos that we had talked about in the
ethical hacking and penetration testing
module we are going to look at three
different demos the first one is going
to be a sql injection attack that we are
going to perform on this tool that we
have the second one is a password
cracking attack on windows 7 and the
third one is a meter breeder based or a
metasploit based shell shock attack on a
linux based web server so let's get
cracking i've powered on this virtual
machine which is the ovas broken web
application it is a tool that is
provided for people who want to enhance
their skills and they can practice how
to do these attacks in a legal manner so
we are going to go to this site i'm just
going to open up my browser the ip
address is 71.132
and that's the uh overs broken web
application that we want to utilize we
are going to head off to mutilate a2 and
we are going to look at a sql injection
attack where we want to bypass
authentication now this takes us to the
login screen so we can just try unlock
here and see that the authentication
mechanism works the account does not
exist so the username and password that
we have supplied is not the correct one
so we want to ensure that there's a sql
database and we can try to attack it and
see uh if we can bypass the
authentication now
uh what we want to do is we want to
create a sql based malform query that
can give us a different output so i'm
just going to type in a single quote
over here and type login and you can see
that this is now suddenly recognized as
a operator and there's an error that is
given out compared to the login that we
tried
earlier when we used a proper text based
login mechanism it gave us the account
does not exist but here the signal code
gave us a error and it shows us how sql
works this is the query that we had
created now in the trainings that you
have for ethical hacking there would be
explanations of what this queries are
all about how the syntax works here
we're just going to see if we can create
a malformed query to log in as a user in
this case so what i'm going to do is uh
create the query over here and we're
going to give it a comparison so we're
going to give it r one equals one space
hyphen hyphen space and if you now click
login you should be able to bypass
authentication and you can see user has
been authenticated and we now have admin
access to this application now here the
sql queries need to be crafted in such a
perspective that they're going to work
so there would be a lot of exercise in
identifying what the database is there's
a microsoft database an oracle database
and so on so forth and then you have to
choose those proper commands but
identifying that would come in the
training right now we're just looking at
a demo this is how a sql injection
attack works now let me log out here
similarly now we are in a login page the
same query worked wonders where it
allowed us to bypass authentication so
it also depends on what kind of a page i
am and what query would be accepted at
this point in time so here application
understanding would also come into the
picture where uh which function we are
calling upon when we are connected to a
particular page now this is a user
lookup function right so again here we
try the same method test test that's not
going to work authentication error bad
user or password and if you type in the
same query over here single quote or and
give it a condition single quote or one
equals one space hyphen knife in space
now here it is not going to log us in
because this is not a login page this is
a user lookup form so here it will
instead give us a dump of all the
databases that it has so you can see all
the usernames and passwords coming in
that are stored in the user lookup field
so this is where the understanding comes
in of which query to create at what page
we are depending upon the function that
is being called right so that's the sql
uh injection attack that we wanted to
look at let's move on to password
tracking now this is a windows 7 machine
that we have i'm just going to do a very
basic password tracking example we're
just going to log in now here the
assumption is that we are able to log in
we have access to a computer and we want
to check out other users who are using
this computer and see if we can find out
their passwords so that we can log in as
a different user steal data if required
and we wouldn't be to blame if there are
any locks that are created so here we've
got a tool called k enable that is
installed right here now i'm already an
administrator on this machine i'm
checking out other administrators who
share the same privileges or any other
user who may be on this system whose
password i can crack and thus i would be
able to get access to their account and
then do any malicious activity right so
this allows me to go into a cracker tool
and it allows me to enumerate this
machine and identify all the users and
passwords that are there in this
particular machine right so i'm just
going to click on the plus sign and i'm
going to import hashes from a local
system so where are these files stored
where does windows store its passwords
in what format are they stored and what
this tool does to retrieve those that's
something that we all need to know as
ethical hacker right so import the
hashes from local system click on next
it's going to enumerate that file and it
is going to give you a list of all the
users that are there so you can see the
users are hacker admin test the one that
we are logged in as and then the user
called virus as well and you can see
that this is the hash value of the
password that is being utilized now
there's a particular format for the hash
value for windows and how it stores but
once we have these hash values let's say
if i want to crack this password there
are various attacks that we can do for
example a dictionary based attack or a
brute force attack let's try a brute
force attack right ntlm is the hashing
mechanism that is used by windows so we
are going to try to create an ntlm hash
attack and here we are going to use a
predetermined rule set for example we
are not sure what characters are being
utilized over here so we just create an
attack like this using all characters
and lowercase a through z uppercase a
through z numeric zero through nine and
all the special characters let's say the
password is between seven and sixteen
characters and this is the character set
that you want to try the brute force
attack on what is a brute force attack
it is an attack where the computer is
going to try each and every permutation
and combination out of this character
set and try to figure out if the
password is going to be correct so if we
click start it's going to start with a
particular characters and then it is
going to identify if that ntlm hash is
going to work against this character and
you can see the time is going to be
phenomenal over here so it's not
necessary that this attack would be
viable it will be 100 successful given
the time frame however the time frame is
huge enough for this attack to become a
little bit redundant there are other
attacks that we can do which can easily
videos so that's how we can get access
to users and passwords there are
different mechanisms where let's say we
don't have login access then what are we
going to do how we can create a fake
user login or how we can remotely access
a machine and then try to get the same
access and that is what we are going to
try to do in the next demo on a linux
machine so what we are doing in a linux
machine could also be doable on the
windows machine with a different exploit
so what i'm going to do is this is the
linux web server that i have that i'm
going to power on i'm going to use a
kali linux machine to hack that device
and i'm going to just power off my
windows 7 machine give it a minute till
it boots up now this is also a demo
machine that we have which has its own
pre-configured vulnerabilities so here
we decide shell shock vulnerability
affects linux mac and unix-based
operating systems for a particular
version of the bash shell bash is the
bone again shell which is the command
line interface in these operating
systems so what we are trying to do here
is we are going to use the kali linux
machine try to find out the
vulnerability over here and if it exists
we are going to use metasploit to attack
this machine now the first and foremost
thing is we want to identify the ip
address we have no idea what the ip
address is we are in the same subnet so
we are assuming that we are able to
connect to this machine so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to open up a
tool called zenmap i'm going to open up
a command line interface find out what
my ip address is and my appearance is
this with a subnet mask of five two five
five two five five dot zero so i want to
see if there are any other machines that
are live in the same subnet and we are
doing a pink swipe over here to identify
which machines are 3254 and 128 we know
that we are 128 at this point in time uh
250 that we want to look at and let's
then try to see if we can scan that
machine one third running over there and
if it is whether the pintest
machine that we were looking for give us
the ports that are open and the details
about those ports and somewhere here it
will tell us that this is the pentester
lab machine that we wanted which is
correct so now we want to do a
vulnerability analysis on this what
we're going to do is i'm going to use
another gui based tool called sparta
which i can just find out from here
sparta uses two tools in the background
a nmap tool and a tool called nikto so
we're just going to start scanning
192.168.71.133 was the ip address add to
scope and over a period of time you can
see all of these will start populating
with information there we are that's the
nikto tool coming in scanning on port 80
which is uh which means that it's a web
server using http it tells us it's an
apache
http 2.2.21
and that gives us the 22 port number as
well if we head over to the tab of nicto
or let's look at the screenshot first
this is what the website would be
looking like and nikto gives us the
options over here it tells us that there
is a vulnerability over here for shell
shock and this is the part where the
vulnerability is going twice all these
other windows and we are going to open
up metasploit metasploit is a
penetration testing tool that is used by
most hackers and ethical hackers to test
applications and already around 1700
exploits right here uh we're going to
see all those exploits with these
commands there we are sorry for the typo
and it will just give us a list of all
the exploits that are stored in
metasploit in this version so all of
these are windows based if we scroll up
we will be looking at other
vulnerabilities as well or exploits the
unique space exploits linux osx
multi-exploits and we're looking for a
exploit for um multi-based apache or
looking for apache mod cgi bash
environmental executable so what we're
going to do is we're just going to copy
it go back to the bottom say use exploit
and paste the one that we wanted press
enter
say show options so it will ask us to
configure this i'm just going to
configure it based on the knowledge that
we have set our host which is the remote
host the victims machine so we put in
the ip address it asks us for the target
uri so that's the path that we saw set
target uri to
cgi hyphen bin slash status enter now
with exploit we need to find a payload
that is going to give us the output that
we want so we say show payloads and it
will give us a list of all the
compatible payloads with this exploit
and we want to create a reverse tcp
connection which is this so we know it's
a linux operating system we want this
payload to be set so set payload press
enter that's the payload coming in show
options now that we have set the payload
this is the options for the exploit and
now we want to set our options for the
payloads as well so we are creating a
reverse tcp connection to our machine
which means we need to set up a listener
so i need to put my ip address over here
set localhost or lhost
192.168.71 make sure everything is fine
which looks like it is and we then type
in the word exploit so that it will
start this attack you can see that it
has created a mutable session at the
victim site and it has opened up a
session so if i do a pwd now pwd is a
linux command for present working
directory and it will show us that we'll
connect it to where w cgi hyphen bin do
an ls it will list all the files that's
the status file over there do a cd
backslash it will take us to the root of
this machine now remember we saw the
passwords on a windows machine similarly
we can head over to the cd shadow now
psswd is the file where linux stores it
user names and shadow is the file where
passwords are shown so do a cat command
psswd and you can see these users coming
up so you can see the last user pen test
lab and you can see there are no
passwords so let's do a cat shadow and
that's your hash value for the password
that you stand and we need to create
based on the vulnerabilities that exist
on different machines so we just looked
at windows and linux and how we can
exploit them depending on existing
vulnerabilities as an ethical hacker
this is uh what we need to learn in our
trainings and then we need to clear our
exams based on this knowledge of how
these things the penetration testing
jobs so let's begin with what is sql
injection
as the name suggests sql injection
vulnerability allows an attacker to
inject malicious any language which is a
language used by an application to
interact with the database now normally
this attack is targeted towards a
database to extract
the data that is stored within however
the vulnerability does not lie in the
database itself the vulnerability will
always lie in the application
it is the developer's prerogative of how
to develop the application how to
configure it to prevent sql injection
queries from happening
a database is created to answer
questions and if a question is asked it
is supposed to answer it database needs
to be configured for some amount of
security but the vulnerability the flaw
here for sql injection will always lie
in the application itself it does how
the application interacts with the
database that needs to be modified that
needs to be maintained by the developer
rather than just configuring the
database itself so the attacker at this
point in time when they sent a query to
the application
will form a malform query by injecting a
particular command or an operator that
is recognized by the sql language
and if that operator is passed through
the application to the database
then the database
basically gets cracked or does a data
dump because of that
unwanted character coming in so this
character needs to be filtered at the
application level itself
now let's look at a quick demo
so what we have done here is i have this
virtual machine
called ovasp broken web applications
virtual machine version 1.2 i'm going to
power this
on till this power is on i'm going to
show you where we can download this uh
utility from so you can just
look for wasp broken web application
project download you'll find it on
sourceforge.net
click on the link
you can download the broken web
application project from here this is a
1.9 gb download and you can have a zip
machine directly for vmware or every
oracle virtual box
now this is an application that has been
developed by ovas which stands for open
web application security project which
is a not-for-profit organization
and uh periodically releases the most
top 10 risks that an application
will face for that particular year
so they have given a web application
uh with inbuilt vulnerabilities for
professionals like us to practice upon
to develop
our skills upon because doing this in
the real world is illegal
i cannot go on to a website to
demonstrate how a sequel injection
attack works
neither should you try your hands on it
till you become very well rehearsed with
it so till to upgrade your skills to up
skill yourself please download this
machine host it in a vmware workstation
or an oracle virtual box and you can
then try your skills
on it
right so
just going back to the browser here if i
open up
a new tab you will see that this machine
has booted up and has an ip address
called 71.132
so if i just go on to that ip address
and i type in 192 168
71.132
and you'll see the os broken web
application project and there are a lot
of training applications realistic
intentionally vulnerable applications
old versions of real applications and so
on so forth so there is a lot of
applications in built over here that you
can try your skills upon we are going to
try to use the ova's mutility over here
uh this gives you the uh os top 10 risks
for 2010 2013 2017 is the latest one so
far
uh but the difference between 2013 and
2017 is that some of these have changed
but not all of them
the order has changed a little bit but
you can see that sequel injection is on
the top a1 amongst the injection attacks
right and you can see there are multiple
types that have been given here the
sequel injection for extracting data or
sql injection for bypass authentication
or insert your injection
attacks blind sql injection and then
there is a tool called sql map which is
available freely on your linux machines
kali linux or parrot linux whichever you
want to use
for your practice targets
and so on so forth so if i just take you
here for bypass authentication
and this is a regular login page that an
application may have right you look at a
username you like a password you type
that in and you log in
so let's say i don't know a password
here i'm just going to type in the
username test password is psswrd
i try to log in and it shows me that the
account does not exist so the
authentication mechanism does work
i did try typing a username and password
it wasn't recognized so the account does
not exist
now let's try to type in a sql query
here i'm going to just give it a single
quote which is an operator that is
recognized by the sql language which
when the database tries to execute uh
will cause the database to
dump some data or to bypass
authentication in this case and i'm
going to give it a condition single
quote
or
one equals one
space hyphen iphone space
and i'm going to click on login now
right now i'm not logged in at all and
we tried our username and password and
we weren't able to log in so now if i
log in you will see that it give me a
status update saying the user has been
authenticated and i'm logged in as admin
got root
so that is what these sql queries can
achieve
i'm going to log out right now and we're
going to look at the basics of sql
injection so looking at that small demo
looking now let's look at what types of
sql injections are available so the
first is in-band sql injection the there
are two sub-types within in-band
error-based injection attack and a
union-based injection attack the second
type is blind sql injection attack where
there's a boolean based and a time based
attack and the third one is out of
bounds equal injection attack now what
is in-band sql injection attack in band
is where we are either attempting the
error based or the union based what is
error-based
uh we send a query to the database we
craft a query to the database and uh
it generates an error miss message
and it dumps the error message right in
front of us on the screen
that
makes us realize that there is a flaw
and there is some information that is
dumped on the screen which we can then
further utilize to craft our further
queries as we go ahead
whereas
union base is the it is where we combine
multiple statements at the same time so
if you look at the url uh earlier in the
url you would see a large structure in
that url uh we can try to add more two
or more statements within the url itself
to combine them and then confuse the
database into executing both the
statements together and giving a data
dump at the same time
right so what would an error-based sql
injection look like if i go back to the
same database which is here
right and if you remember the username
we gave it a single quote or
one equals one space hyphen knife and
space we gave it the condition right so
basically what it did was a single quote
is an operator that goes to the database
selects the default uh table in the user
tables in this database column
and then
compares it to the condition that is
given so the condition that we gave was
one equals one which is always true so
what it did was it selected the default
uh user table that was available in the
database
and instead of comparing it to a
password it compared it to the condition
so if i give it one equals two where the
condition is false and if i log in you
will see that the account doesn't exist
comes back again because the condition
was false and instead of comparing the
user account to the password it
basically
compare the user account to the
condition so if i give it a single quote
or
one equals one
hyphen iphone space
and log in you can see that this is a
correct condition and thus we are able
to log in now before we even go uh to
that extent if i just forget the
condition over here and just give it a
single quote the operator and i send
this operator to the database and i
click on login you will see that it
generates an error which is right on top
and it tells us the line the
file where the error happened and you
can see it happened in the
mysqlhandler.php file
right and then it gave us the message
you have an error in your sql syntax
check the manual that corresponds to
your mysql server version for the right
syntax to use now why would a hacker
want to do this in the first place
because there are different types of
databases
so there is a mysql ms sql or microsoft
sql oracle sql ibm db2 all of these are
variations of the sql database uh they
use the sql language however every
database has its own command
right there they have their own syntax
they have their own uh specific commands
that are utilized for the database so in
this scenario the hacker wants to
identify what database is being
currently utilized so
they can craft those particular queries
so now with this injection with just me
sending the quote and the error getting
generated i now come to know that we are
using a mysql server and the version of
that server is 5.1.73
and the rest of the information about uh
where the handlers are located and so on
so forth
right this gives the information to the
hacker of how they want to proceed next
what kind of queries they want to create
what kind of syntax they want to utilize
so
error-based attack is where you generate
these kind of errors uh and you get this
information the union base is where you
craft your queries within the url uh you
can
try to
combine multiple statements within the
input fields and try to generate a
response from that then we come to
boolean based sql injection
uh sends a sql query to the database
which forces the application to return a
different result depending on whether
the query returns a true or a false
result so basically if
the input is false the input both the
inputs are false the output would be
false uh there's one input that is false
the other input that is true input b the
output would be true and so on so forth
right so depending on the result from
the inputs the attacker will come to
know which input is true with this he
can then access the database of the
website so you're trying to figure out
by sending out multiple inputs and then
analyzing the output to see what exactly
which command exactly work what was the
resultant output of that command thus
from this kind of an information the
hacker can infer their next step forward
then you have time-based sql injections
now there are times when a database
administrator or an application
administrator has done some security
configuration and does have disabled
verbose error messages now what is a
verbose error message the error message
that we saw right here
is a verbose error message that means
that the message gives out details the
message gives out details about what the
database is the version and whatnot so
if
they have sanitized these errors
and you no longer can generate these
errors and thus you cannot figure out
what database is then what do you do
right for example if i just take you to
simply learn
and
take you to a url that is supposedly not
accessible you can see that that gives a
generic error
oops layer it looks like you have crash
landed on mars it doesn't give you a
verbose error that we saw here so this
gives us a detail error of what went
wrong where it gives us the database the
version of the database and uh where the
query went wrong and etc etc etc whereas
on this side where there's some there's
a lot of security that goes in here so
you can see that it doesn't generate a
error
you just get a generic page in front of
you so in that case what does a hacker
do so the hacker then injects a
time-based
uh query in the url which allows us
to verify whether the command is being
executed or not so we put in a time wait
let's say 10 seconds of time wait so if
we the moment we inject the query if the
query times for 10 seconds and then gets
executed that means that the sql
injection is possible however
if we inject the query and uh it just
gets executed without the delay that
means that the time uh injection attack
would not be uh possible on that
particular site out of bound is not a
very common attack it depends on the
features being cleared enabled in the
database management system that has been
used by the web application so this can
be a somewhat of a misconfiguration
error
by the database administrator where you
have enabled functions
and not sanitize them so you have not
done in
access controls properly you have not
given account control so
queries should never be executed at an
administrative level they should always
be
executed at a user level with minimum
privileges that are required for that
query to be executed now if you're
allowing these kind of functions
to be to be enabled at the dbms and
there is an administrative account that
can have access to them at that point in
time an out of bound injection attack is
possible so let's look at how a website
works
right
how sql works on a website now the
website is constructed of html hypertext
markup language
which would include javascripting for
functionality cascading style sheet for
the mapping of the website right and
then react.js and whatnot
for further functionality now when we
send a query to the website it is
normally using the http protocol on
https protocol when the query reaches
the application the application would
then go ahead and generate the sql query
uh at the client side you'll have
all these scripting languages coming in
on the front end uh that we can utilize
to craft queries and then send them
across at the server side you'll have uh
databases like oracle mysql ms sql and
so on so forth that will then execute
those queries right so just to give you
an example if i use a tool called
postman
what we generally do
when we craft a query is we send out a
get request
to the website and then we receive a
response from the site with the html
code and everything so this is a tool
that is utilized by software testers to
test the responses that you're going to
get from various websites so on the left
hand side you can see i've used it on
quite a bit
uh here we have an example for gmail.com
so let's continue with that so this is a
get request being sent to gmail the
moment i send it it's going to create an
http request and send it across the
response that i get is this this is the
html code for gmail.com
right these are the cookies
these are the headers
that include information so you can see
this is a text html character set
utilized is utf-8
and the configuration uh that has been
done with the application right so this
is where uh everything comes in this is
the cookie that has been sent with that
particular request that i had sent out
now if you analyze this query right so
when we went on to this application and
i typed in that single quote and we
generated this error right uh you can
see that the application converted this
into a sql query so the query was select
username from accounts where the
username in quote single quotes and we
use this quote right the single quote
right there
so
uh that's where we use that operator and
that's where the exception error
occurred so these are the kind of
queries that are structured by the
application and then taken on to the
database for execution when we type in
uh it is a http get request with the
username and password within that query
uh that is sent to the application the
application converts it into a sql query
sends it to the database and the
database responds with the appropriate
response
so how do we prevent sql injection in
the first place
use prepared statement and parameterize
queries
these statements make sure that the
parameters pass into sql statements are
treated in a safe manner so for example
we saw that the single quote was an
operator
this shouldn't be allowed to be utilized
in the first place
right so here what we are doing here is
a secure way of running a sql query in
the jdbc using a parameterized statement
define which user we want to find so
there's a string the email comes in
connection to the database we are going
to figure out how the connection is
going to be passed how it is going to be
created construct the sql statement we
want to run specifying the parameter
right so we define how is it going to be
created what is going to be created what
can be passed to the database and what
should not be passed to the database so
that is one way of
utilizing prepared statements and
parameterized queries
then we have object relational mapping
most development
teams prefer to use objection object
relational mapping frameworks to make
the translation of sql results set into
code objects more seamless so this is an
example of
object relational mapping uh where we
map certain objects
and allow that to be executed and then
escaping inputs in a simple way
to protect against most sql injection
attacks many languages have standard
functions to achieve this right so you
need to be very careful while using
escape characters in your code base when
a sql statement is constructed not all
injection attacks rely on abuse of code
characters so you need to know what
characters are being utilized
in the configuration that you have
created in the structure that you have
created in the code that you have
created
uh which characters are being recognized
as operators you need to sanitize those
operators and you need to uh basically
ensure that these operators cannot be
accepted as user input if they are
they're faded out by the application and
they never reach the database other
methods of preventing sql injection are
password hashing so that passwords
cannot be bypassed the passwords cannot
be recovered passwords cannot be cracked
uh third-party authentication you use
what
or
some other service for a single sign-on
mechanism does
you rely on a third party
to maintain the security of
authentication and uh what kind of
parameters are passed for example uh
using linkedin logins or facebook logins
right uh for the layman you normally go
on to facebook and you allow
if you're using a game right if you
start playing a game you're allowed to
log into the game using your facebook
credentials or your google credentials
now that is not just for ease of use but
the game user the developer has
outsourced the authentication mechanisms
to third party such as facebook or
google because they understand
that that authentication mechanism is as
safe as can be
facebook and google are wealthy
organizations uh hire a lot of security
experts and the development for their
authentication mechanisms is top-notch
small organization cannot spend that
kind of money on security itself right
so you use a third-party authentication
mechanism to ensure that
these kind of attacks may not happen
then web application firewalls uh having
a web application firewall and
configuring it properly
for sql injection attacks is one of the
sure shot method of
mitigating or minimizing the uh threat
in the first place so at this point in
time you have realized that the
application has some vulnerabilities for
sql injection and instead of recoding or
restructuring the application uh you
want to take the easier way out or the
cheaper way out so what you do is you
you install a web application firewall
and you configure the web application
firefall to identify malicious queries
and stop them
at the firewall level itself so they
never reach the application and thus the
vulnerabilities of the application don't
get executed
buy better software
and uh keep on updating the software so
it's not necessary that once you have a
software you install it it's going to be
safe for life
new vulnerabilities are discovered every
day every hour and it may so happen what
is secure today
may be completely insecure tomorrow or
the day after right so you need to keep
on upgrading the software if there are
no upgrades available and the
vulnerability still exists you might
want to migrate to a better software and
thus
ensure that you don't get hacked
right always update and use patches
organizations keep on sending out
updates and patches as and when they are
released you need to install them to
enhance your security postures
and then continuously monitor sql
statements and databases use protocol
monitors
use different softwares use the
firewalls to keep on monitoring what
kind of queries you're uh getting and
based on those queries you want to
ensure the inputs and the queries that
are creating uh
are not detrimental to the health of the
software that you have so let's start
looking at the certifications so to be
an ethical hacker you must hold a
certification which specializes in
ethical hacking or in cyber security
companies look for candidates who are
globally certified when we say globally
certified they're looking for a
certificate that has been given by an
organization that is recognized globally
and is well accepted in the industry so
these are the top five certifications
our candidate can obtain the first one
become a certified ethical hacker then
there is global information assurance
certification penetration tester then
offensive security certified
professional comptria pentest plus and
finally the license penetration tester
now these certifications are offered by
different organizations all of these
organizations are recognized globally
and their certifications are well
accepted in the technical space so let's
start off with the certified ethical
hacker and we'll look at the
organizations that provide these
certifications and how we can attain
them so ceh or certified ethical hacker
in its current form is in its version 10
it's been revised and updated over a
period of time ec council is the
certifying authority for ceh they have
their own authorized training centers
through which you can attend trainings
give those exams get yourself certified
and thus become globally certified and
can be eligible to apply for security
related jobs it is a very well known
certification and is widely accepted at
the same time it would test the
candidates knowledge of security threats
and preventive measures now there are
two types of exams that you can give
with ceh one is a multiple choice
question exam which is theoretical in
nature they ask you questions and you
answer the correct uh you select the
correct answers if you clear you get
certified the second certification
nowadays is where there's a practical
exam associated with it that's a you'll
have to purchase the voucher for that
exam and give that exam the practical
exam is held in a virtual lab where they
you're given scenarios and based on
those scenarios you have to resolve the
questions given to you and give proof of
the resolution which would then
get you certified as an ethical hacker
the theoretical exam in this scenario is
the fees is around 500
this is for the multiple choice question
exam
where you can pay the fees and you can
attend through a
online portal and you can give the exam
directly the exam is four hours long in
which you have to answer 125 questions
now four hours for 125 questions seems a
long time but it isn't it's a very
technical exam there are scenario based
questions and it would take some time
for you to analyze and understand the
question and then identify the
equivalent correct answer so it's a very
competitive exam and you'll have to
study really hard to clear this exam as
well the cutoff for passing varies from
60 to 85 percent so there is no exact
grade and all the questions have
different weightages so depending on the
questions that have been given to you
and the way that you have answered them
you would pass at either 60
or you would pass when you scored 85
percent once you are ceh certified which
is a very technical certification you
will be qualified to apply for job roles
as a penetration tester or a security
engineer these are job roles where you
would be responsible of ethically trying
to attack applications
servers switches and try to find out
vulnerabilities within them the training
of this certification will make you
adept in most of these tools that are
required there are a lot of practicals
in this training and if you successfully
completed those practicals clearing the
exam is a queer easy task with the
practicals comes your knowledge and
would help you understand how you would
be performing penetration tests in the
real world an average annual salary in
the usa for a cea certified person is
around ninety one thousand dollars and
in india is around four like seventy six
thousand odd rupees the salaries would
vary as far as organizations are
concerned uh more established
organizations can afford to pay a little
bit more but these are average raw
salaries that we have seen across the
market the next certification is the g
pen also known as the global information
assurance certification penetration
tester this certification looks into the
different pen testing practices and
methods also focuses on the various
problems and pen testing so again this
is where you're getting certified as a
penetration tester so it's again a
technical certification where your
knowledge on networking applications and
security of which would be tested you
will be trained on this of course so the
training will include all these areas
where you need to focus identify those
problems and thus be ready for the real
world scenarios the candidate will have
to understand networking concepts and
operating systems such as linux and
windows and you should be very well
aware of the tcp protocols this is true
for any of the technical certifications
for ethical hacking giac is the
certification provider it's again a very
well renowned and well accepted
certification authority across the globe
the exam fees are 1899.
82 to 115 questions to be answered in
three hours now why 82 215 it depends on
the test that has been associated and
depending on how you're answering those
questions uh you would be given those
many number of questions to begin with
but all of these need to be answered in
three hours 74 is the past percentage
that is required to clear this exam the
average annual salary in the usa is
around 96 000
while in india it is around similar to
certified ethical hacking then looking
at the next certification from offensive
security called the oscp
offensive security certified
professional this is another penetration
testing certification highly technical
in nature and it is an entirely hands-on
certification the previous two
certifications that we saw we talked
about ch where there are two different
exams you could either take the
theoretical exam and give your mcqs or
you could take the practical one here
you don't have an option this is a
practical exam so the test is conducted
on a virtual network so they send out
instructions to you there's a virtual
lab that is given out to you and they
give you the questions and you have to
perform those assessments create those
reports and provide it to the certifying
authority in this case offensive
security uh if you match their criterias
of whatever you have identified in those
reports you get certified here the
requirements of good understanding of
networking protocols how systems
function how kali linux operating system
functions and the candidate must for
complete offensive securities
penetration testing with the kali linux
course and pass the hands-on exam so
this focuses purely on kali linux kali
line next is an operating system that is
freely distributed over the internet and
comes structured with around 300 plus
tools used for ethical hacking so this
course totally relies on kali linux for
you to use as a tool set for penetration
testing the certificate provider as
stated is offensive security the name of
the course is oscp offensive security
certified professional exam is around
800 to
1550. now understand that this exam is
technical and is hands-on so for you to
prepare for this exam they come up with
virtual labs where you can start
practicing and honing your skills
depending on the number of days for
which you have purchased the access to
that particular labs the amount will
vary from eight hundred dollars which
would be the minimum access days
available to one thousand five hundred
and fifty dollars where the maximum
number of days would be given to you for
practicing once you're ready even during
the time spa time span of where you have
that access once you're ready for the
exam you can they can attempt the exam
and clear the average annual salary is
similar around 91 000 for the u.s market
and 905 000 rupees in the indian market
then looking at the comchia pen test
plus comptia is another certification
authority or a certification provider a
training provider that that will help
you get yourself certified in the
ethical hacking space so they have
certification called pen test plus which
is focused towards penetration testing
so it is an intermediate level
certification it assesses the
vulnerability assessment and the
penetration testing skills of a
candidate here the training will provide
you with all the essentials where it
will help you identify how to do
vulnerability assessments how to
identify those vulnerabilities and then
which tools to utilize for what kind of
a penetration test for the requirements
a minimum of three to four years of
hands-on experience in the information
security field also a computer security
plus or a network plus or equivalent
knowledge is required so in the network
plus they talk about securing networks
and they help you understand the osi
layers the tcp layers and help you
understand the protocols and all of
those things so having that knowledge is
an added advantage the certificate
provider is comchia and the cost of the
exam is around 349
maximum number of questions
is 85 and i think it's a three hour exam
the passing percentage is uh scoring 750
marks out of a possible 900. so the
scale is the minimum you can ever score
is 100 if you're completely unbe
prepared the maximum you can score is
900 uh you get a leeway of 150 marks for
your certifications so you have to score
a minimum of 750 to clear the exam
average annual salary for a hampshire
certified penetration test plus
professional is 97 000 in the u.s market
and in the indian market it would be
around 5 lakh rupees then comes the
license penetration tester now this is
an advanced certificate again from ec
council this is where ec council gives
you a license which certifies that you
have undergone thorough training and
have cleared your exam in which you can
conduct or lead a audit for
vulnerability assessment and penetration
testing it is an expert level
certification comes after the ceh
certification it is the ultimate test
which tests this candidate's penetration
testing skills so there are two
certifications over here one is the ecsa
ec council certified security analyst
once you clear that you get you can
appear for the license penetration
tester both of these are hands-on
certifications so you will be given a
virtual lab you will be given a scenario
in which you'll have to perform some
assessments create reports submitted to
the ec council they will analyze your
reports if they meet the criteria that
have been identified you would then be
certified as a licensed penetration
tester the candidate must be above 18
years of age a recertification is
required every three years so the
validity is three years after three
years you will have to be recertified or
there is a continuing point education
system over there where you can score
points by publishing articles by
attending trainings or giving out
trainings and carrying areas of
recertified it is preferred that the
candidate has ceh and the ecsa
certification so the previous
certification that we saw certified
ethical hacker and then the ecsa ec
council certified security analyst after
which you can appear for the lpt license
penetration tester the certificate
provider again is ec council the license
penetration tester exam has it if the
candidate must purchase an exam
dashboard for 899 dollars which is valid
for a year so once you purchase the
voucher the validity is one year you can
prepare
and attain the certification only once
you're ready the exam can be scheduled
and you can give that exam the exam
consists of three different levels each
level has three different challenges the
candidate must pass at least one
challenge in order to qualify for the
next level and for each level the
ex-hours so this is a grueling exit
hands-on they're giving you challenges
and they are going to
test you on your skills as a penetration
so be ready to be very hands-on for this
kind of application average annual
salary
and up
to the
networks programs computer systems and
their components from unauthorized
digital axes and attacks did you know
that according to the universe attack
every 39 seconds that is on an average
2244 times a day
now that's a huge number
with that we have reached the end of day
two of our cyber security week on day
three which is tomorrow we are going to
focus on the core cybersecurity concepts
thank you all for watching today's live
session i hope it was useful and
interesting see you tomorrow thanks
again and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you